und
So eine Platte habe ich mir ausgedruckt, dass ich meinen Accesspoint an die Decke hängen kann.
Wobei ich hier nicht an die Decke gehauen habe, weil ich dachte mir so eine Decke hält es wahrscheinlich nicht so gut aus, das ist ja so eine dünne Gipsdecke.
Deswegen habe ich mir noch so ein Mountingwinkel für ein Brett an der Wand ausgedruckt.
Zumindest kann man da seinen Accesspoint mounten, aber natürlich, wow, was ist das für ein Geruckel, 0W.
Nachdem das erste was passiert ist, dass diese Dinger hier abgebrochen sind.
Aber das ist nicht schlimm, weil ich habe dann diese Inserts reingeschmolzen.
Die haben wir uns hier schon im Stream angeguckt, ich habe so Inserts, die man reinschmelzen kann in 3D gedrucktes Zeug.
Und dann kannst du Metallschrauben reinschrauben.
Und das habe ich ausgedruckt, ich muss sagen, das hängt jetzt an der Wand.
Ich habe ein Foto gemacht, aber ich kann euch das Foto gerade nicht zeigen.
Weil ich habe es auf dem Handy und ich weiß nicht wie ich das gescheit rüber kriege ohne Upload und Download und Geschiss.
Das funktioniert tatsächlich erstaunlich gut, hätte ich gar nicht gedacht.
Mounting Platte ans Brett, Accesspoint an die Platte gehängt und wunderbar.
Pog.
Libulon, Dankeschön, 29 Monate Hypersubscription hier.
Oh, falscher Knopf, falscher Knopf.
Das wollte ich eigentlich.
Team Sound, das sind alle gleich, das sind Vogue.
Vogue sind die dann, Vogue.
Ist noch früh, ist noch vor neun, so früh bin ich normalerweise nie an oder?
Ich bin schon seit acht oder so am Rechner, habe ein bisschen rumgeklickt,
habe schon ein paar Videos aufgemacht, was man sich dann angucken kann.
Natürlich, der übliche Level Cap G-Bait muss auch sein.
Leute, ich muss euch sagen, der Eurovision Song Contest ging mir so am Arsch vorbei.
Ich kann das immer nicht verstehen, dass da Leute jedes Jahr sich diesen Krempel echt angucken.
Belangloser könnte es kaum sein.
Aber Twitter, ich habe ja den Fehler gemacht, ich hätte es gar nicht mitbekommen.
Hätte ich nicht die Twitter Trends mal Just For Fun, ich kann es teilweise nicht lassen,
die Twitter Trends doch mir mal auf Deutsch angeguckt.
Da habe ich mitbekommen, dass dieser Krempel wieder ist.
Ich habe auch gelesen, wir sind letzter geworden, aber es geht mir so massiv am Arsch vorbei.
Es gibt wirklich nicht viel, was mich weniger interessiert.
Ja, es gibt bei euch ein neues Chat, außer dass ihr noch schlauer geworden seid.
Das geht ja gar nicht anders.
Ihr wisst ja, mit jedem Sub-Kollektiv++IQ, und wohlgemerkt, es ist++IQ und nicht IQ++,
weil ihr wisst ja alle, was der Unterschied ist.
++IQ wird gemacht, bevor die restliche Expression ausgewertet wird, und IQ++ danach.
Und natürlich ist der Chat davor schlau.
Meistens macht es keinen Unterschied, immer ein++ davor oder++ danach schreibt er aber.
So, ansonsten, lasst mal überlegen, gab es die Woche noch irgendwelche weiteren spannenden
Dinge?
Also ich habe gelesen, irgendein Artikel bei der CT, da können wir uns nachher sogar ein
Video angucken, dass Windows 11 immer noch kacke ist, also ich hatte recht, wenn sogar
die CT das schreibt.
Gab es Sturmschäden bei euch, Katze nicht weggeflogen?
Nein, es gab gar nichts.
Die Bäume haben sich ganz schön gebogen, ist aber nichts umgefallen.
Es gibt ja auch nicht mal viel zum umfallen, ein Baum vom Nachbar ist irgendwie vor einem
Jahr oder so schon umgefallen und hat bei uns den Zaun platt gemacht.
Aber zum Glück nur den Zaun, sonst nichts.
Die Katze hat ein sehr gutes Gespür dafür, wann scheiß Wetter draußen ist, und setzt
sich dann entweder unter das Sofa oder in den Schrank oder sonst wo und versteckt sich.
Wieso ist PHP scheiß?
So scheiß ist PHP doch gar nicht.
Kommt drauf an, was man mit PHP verwendet, also wenn man jetzt, sag mal mal, so RAW PHP
macht mit Session Handling und dem ganzen Krempel von Hand, dann ist es scheiß, weil
die Sprache an sich muss ich ehrlich sagen, naja.
Ist ein bisschen her, dass ich was mit PHP gemacht habe, aber die Sprache an sich war,
ja, die konnte man schon verwenden, aber so die schönste war es nicht.
Ja, dann ist eklig, dann ist eklig.
Die ERK Zwischenprüfung war Monarch S.
Was wollten die da, es ist eigentlich mittlerweile so, dass die Zwischenprüfung in irgendeiner
Art und Weise zur Abschlussnote dabei zählt.
Also bei mir war die Zwischenprüfung einfach nur komplett just for fun.
Die musste man machen, aber es war komplett egal, ob man sie gemacht hat oder nicht.
Ich glaube aber mittlerweile, dass die Zwischenprüfung in irgendeiner Art und Weise mit zählt.
Aber was ab diesem Jahr ernsthaft wirklich, das haben die uns damals schon erzählt.
Und damals, also ich habe die Ausbildung 2007 gemacht, das haben die uns damals schon erzählt.
Ja, wir haben Glück, bald ist die Zwischenprüfung auch in der Abschlussnote.
Und dann haben die allen ernst jetzt 15 Jahre gebraucht von der Ankündigung, dass es bald
soweit ist.
Gut, es wundert mich bei der ERK auch nichts mehr.
15 Jahre bei der ERK ist wahrscheinlich morgen so.
Mittlerweile heißt sie auch AP1.
Okay, mit der weiß eh kein Mensch für was diesen ganzen Abkürzungskram steht.
Game up, danke für 19 Monate Hypersubscription hier.
Habe ich den eigentlich noch für Krempel auf?
Was?
Mein PC von 2017?
Ne, den brauchen wir jetzt nicht.
Aber den können wir mal auflassen, den brauchen wir.
Dicewift, das haben wir schon gesehen.
Ja, ja, alles klar.
Warum habe ich Chip auf?
Wer macht denn Chip freiwillig aus?
Das Strukturizer?
Nein, alles zumachen.
Tabs schließen.
Tabs.
Alles.
Ja, das habe ich übrigens mittlerweile bei mir daheim laufen, falls sich das einer fragt.
Da hatten wir uns da angeguckt, meine Wetterstation ist jetzt komplett über Home Assistant
erreichbar.
Soll ich euch mal einen Screenshot zeigen?
Ich zeige euch mal einen Screenshot.
Deck.
Auschamp.
Ok, das Fenster ist ein bisschen zu klein, ist nicht ausgeschrieben, aber es passt schon.
So sieht meine Wetterstation, so sieht meine Wetterstation Daten jetzt im Home Assistant
aus.
Außentemperatur.
Sowohl die richtige Außentemperatur als auch die gefühlte Außentemperatur, das macht
er irgendwie anhand des Windes fest oder so, keine Ahnung, aber es unterscheidet sich
manchmal.
Ja, ja, das ist der Unterschied, das ist das was dir die Wetterberichte, also die Wetterfeuersage
auch immer erzählt, und zwar wenn es beispielsweise 12, 13 Grad draußen ist, aber es ist nass
und es regnet, es hat geregnet und es bläst viel Wind, dann ist die gefühlte Temperatur
deutlich unter der eigentlichen Außentemperatur.
Tatsächlich ganz sinnvolle Geschichte hier.
Wind, Wind ist gerade nicht vorhanden, deswegen ist gefühlte Außentemperatur ziemlich gleich,
Regen gibt es auch gerade nicht und Feinstaub ist tatsächlich ziemlich gering.
Wir haben gerade 69 Zuschauer, Gatschi-Buzz, quasi kaum Feinstaub, aber heute ist Sonntag
und es fährt auch keiner draußen rum und sonst was.
Oh, es sieht aus, aber das stimmt gar nicht für heute, aber macht aber nix, weiß eh
nicht ob da eigentlich jemand reinguckt noch, doch, aber es ist schön, dass jeder schreibt,
wobei doch, da gucken Leute rein, ich sehe das Kommando öfters mal.
Hype Train is close, ah verpasst, Hype Train, gibt Schlimmeres, ganze, Jeff braucht nicht
noch neues Raumschiff.
So sieht es aus, ja und ansonsten gibt es eigentlich die Woche nicht sonderlich viel
spannendes glaube ich, oder war glaube ich nicht sonderlich viel spannendes.
Ich hab meinen Einkaufstream immer noch nicht beendet fällt mir ein, wir haben die Hälfte
von dem was wir brauchen erst, aber machen wir irgendwann die Tage fertig.
Ich überleg grad, war die Woche irgendwas spannendes wo ich jetzt grad nicht dran denke,
mal kurz drüber scrollen, haben wir nicht immer nur Wochenzusammenfassungen oder sowas?
Keine Ahnung, es war glaube ich die Woche erstaunlich wenig.
Auf der Arbeit habe ich wieder extrem viel gemietet, weil mieten ja mittlerweile das
ist wofür man bezahlt wird.
Das ist teilweise echt lustig, wenn man sich überlegt, eigentlich wird man da bezahlt
dafür, dass man Ahnung von, wie wird es meine Oma sagen, Computerzeug hat, dass man sich
ganz gut mit Computer auskennt, würde man eigentlich vermuten, aber mittlerweile ist
es so, dass mindestens 50% eigentlich von jeder x-beliebigen 0815 ahnungslosen Person
ausgeführt werden könnte.
Also im Prinzip bezahlen die mich für was was ich gar nicht mache, weil ich viel zu
viel mieten muss.
Also eigentlich bräuchte man mich vom Knowhow gar nicht, sondern mich in Person von mieten
vielleicht.
Man könnte auch jemand anderes für mich mieten lassen und dann könnte ich mehr Sachen machen
auf die ich Bock habe und die Firma wird auch mehr für ihr Geld kriegen, aber das wollen
sie nicht.
Hast du die API von Roku, ja habe ich das funktioniert mittlerweile.
Ich lade euch jetzt, ich lade euch das, ich muss mal kurz gucken, ob ich das Bild nicht
auch irgendwie hochladen kann.
Kennt jemand einen guten Image-Haus, der da nicht Image-U-Dingsbums-Immigure oder so
ist?
Ich lade das einfach.
Choose Image, Photo Library, ich zeige euch, ich zeige euch die Bilder mal, Fogchamp, Fogchamp
Bilder zeige ich euch.
Moment, Moment, ich zeige euch das, wenn der Upload funktioniert, ich lade das gerade auf
wegen so einer Image-Seite hoch hier, ok, Moment, Post-Image, habe ich euch die Bilder
von meinem Access-Point hochgeladen mit dem 3D gedruckten Frame, der ist jetzt im Einsatz,
also guckt mal, das ist das, was ich meine, ich hatte Angst, dass meine Decke das nicht
aushält.
Ja und bevor jetzt einer kommt, das Brett ist nicht richtig abgeschnitten, ich weiß,
das habe ich nicht abgeschnitten.
Das hatte ich noch, rumliegen, das ist von irgendwas, fragt man aus der Küche oder so,
keine Ahnung.
Zumindest ich habe die Mounting Plate ausgedruckt, muss ich euch mal zeigen, tatsächlich ganz,
ganz praktisch.
Ich habe diese Platte ausgedruckt zum Mounten und damit der Access-Point unten dran hält,
habe ich Inserts reingeschmolzen mit dem Lötkolben, das sind so, so hier, Threaded Inserts, irgendwie
so heißt der Kram, das da, das ist, das sind Metalldinger, hier sieht man es, guck, so
sieht das aus, das sind so Metalldinger, die schmilzt man mit dem Lötkolben in 3D gedruckte
Plastik rein und dann kann man da Schrauben reinschrauben und die halten tatsächlich,
da würde ich das gar nicht denken, aber guck, so, warum sollte ich Decke nicht haben, weil
das dünnes Gips ist, guck mal, so, du schmilzt das da rein, ob du da Löcher drunter machst
oder nicht, ist eigentlich ziemlich egal, du schmilzt das da rein, so, und dann lässt
du, lässt du das mal 2-3 Minuten abkühlen, dann hast du ein Gewinde in deinem 3D Druck
drinnen, so, und so habe ich das hier auch gemacht, ich habe ein Gewinde in meinem,
Onks, Alter, was für eine Auflösung das iPhone hat, das fällt mir immer erst dann
wieder auf, ich habe jetzt ein Gewinde in meinem 3D Druck drinnen, woran ich dann 2,
wo ich 2 Schrauben reingedreht habe, so, und daran kann man jetzt den Access Point hängen,
achja, das andere habe ich auch aus dem 3D Drucker, hier so komische Winkel für das
Brett, hält alles bombenfest, so, und dann habe ich den Access Point da unten dran, hier
hängen, kann man in Plastik Gewinde schneiden, ja, das ist das, was ich gerade gezeigt habe,
du nimmst so fertige Metalldinger und schmilzt die mit dem Lötkolben in dein 3D gedrucktes
Objekt rein, und da kannst du dann Schrauben rein drehen, und das ist richtig fest, achso,
ja, du kannst Schrauben rein machen in 3D gedrucktes Zeug, aber nach, ein bisschen,
also, das ist nicht sonderlich, ja, schön, also, du könntest das wahrscheinlich gut
machen, wenn du größere, dickere Schrauben nimmst, aber die meisten Modelle haben dafür
gar keinen Platz, um irgendwie sonderlich dicke Schrauben zu nehmen, ja, du kannst
in 3D gedruckte Sachen reinschrauben, aber, also, sonderlich haltbar ist das nicht, das
mag zwar halten, wenn du es 1, maximal 2 mal öffnest, oder so, aber spätestens mal
im dritten Mal reinrausschrauben, das ist nix, also, so ist es deutlich besser, und
das ist wirklich fest, also, da kannst du dich fast dran hängen, also, das ist wirklich
fest, das würde ich gar, das hätte ich gar nicht gedacht, also, nicht da dran hängen,
aber hier an diese, also, das ist wirklich fest, da wird man gar nicht von ausgehen,
das reicht man nicht einfach so raus, kiff, genau, schon für den Sub, so, und dann hab
ich den Exist Point genommen, und hab den einfach da unten dran gehängt, fertig, das
ist jetzt irgendwie eine andere Auflösung, weil man weiß es nicht genau, so, dann hab
ich einfach den Exist Point genommen und dran gehängt, ich hab das Kabel da noch so an
die Wand gemacht, und gut ist, so, und jetzt hängt der Exist Point drüben, kopfüber,
unter der Decke, so wie das sein muss, die Dinger sind nämlich eigentlich für Ceiling
Mounted gedacht, und ich kann die nicht gescheit an das Ceiling Mounten, weil meine Decke,
man sieht es hier teilweise, das ist ganz dünnes Gips, da hatte ich Schiss, das dran
zu machen, ist der Exist Point riesig, beides bisschen, also, das täuscht schon, weil,
ich mein, guck mal, hier hinten siehst du, hier siehst du quasi das letzte Drittel
von der Tür, das letzte Drittel von der Tür ist ungefähr so lang wie der Exist Point,
oder das letzte Viertel von der Tür, ist ungefähr so lang wie der Exist Point, also,
das täuscht, aber der Exist Point ist jetzt auch nicht der allerkleinste, also, das ist
ein, weiß nicht, ob man das irgendwie mit der Größe, irgendwie vergleichen kann, ob
es da irgendwas gescheites gibt, also, das ist, weiß nicht, ob man die Abmaße da sieht,
das ist by the way falsch, das sieht überhaupt nicht so aus, ja, ja, das sind die Kleinen,
die Kleinen, die sind 13 cm, 13 cm, und der hier ist schon eine ganze Ecke größer, ja,
da ist das relativ fett, aber, wisst ihr, was das gut ist, ich hab jetzt meine vier Unify
Exist Points abgeschaltet, ich hatte ja im Keller, im ersten Stock, im Erdgeschoss und
für die Terrasse draußen ein Unify Exist Point, und oben, erstes Bild, ah ja, tatsächlich
null, ja, 22 cm mal 22 cm, also, das ist ganz schöner Chonker als Exist Point, Pepo Fett
Exist Point, also, der ist schon ordentlich, aber, was halt wirklich nice ist, das Teil
kann jetzt komplett, sag mal, so, ich hab jetzt vier Unify Exist Points abgeschaltet, und
ich hab jetzt nur noch ein Exist Point stehen, der ist oben im Wohnzimmer, also, im ersten
Stock im Wohnzimmer, soweit wie es geht zum Flur, das heißt, es ist die zentralste Position,
wo ich ohne Probleme drankomme, und der versorgt Geräte im Keller, im Erdgeschoss, im ersten
Stock, theoretisch im Dach, bis runter auf die Terrasse und fast zum Eingang vom Garten.
Ein Exist Point, wo ich vorher vier Unify Exist Points hatte, also, da kann ich mich
echt nicht beschweren.
Einzig der Empfang, nicht nur Stromspann, der ist auch von den Features her deutlich
besser, und wenn du näher dran bist, ist er auch noch schneller, obwohl er eine Generation
alt ist.
Das einzige Teil, was etwas Verbindungsprobleme hat, ich muss mal kurz gucken, ob es noch
erreichbar ist, weil sogar die IP-SS ist noch erreichbar, oh, Wi-Fi-Verbindung, MonkaS,
nein, ich benutze keinen Controller, also das einzige Teil von meinen WLAN-Geräten,
was irgendwie Verbindungsprobleme hat, ist im Keller, halb unter der Heizung, nicht unter
der Heizung, hinter der Heizung, eine Steuerung für so einen Wasserhahn, das hat auch die
beschissenste Position, und das verliert manchmal die Verbindung, ihr habt ja gerade gesehen,
manchmal ist das Gerät der Meinung, no pass, kein Bock, das legt sich aber in ein paar
Minuten wieder, dann geht's, das ist natürlich kacke, und deswegen habe ich mir überlegt,
entweder mal gucken, ob ich an den TASmotor-Settings ein bisschen rumbauen kann, alternativ muss
ich vielleicht den Access Point auch noch runterstellen, unten ins Wohnzimmer, wobei
das meine weniger bevorzugte Variante ist, nein, ich benutze nicht den Controller, das
ist Unleashed, nein, das ist kein Mikrotik, nein, ich habe das, was standardmäßig eingestellt
ist, aber dass das Gerät nicht erreichbar ist, liegt wahrscheinlich nicht an der Sendeleistung
irgendwie des Access Points, sondern wahrscheinlich daran, dass der ESP866 im Keller nicht genug
übertragen, also selbst nicht genug auf die Reihe bekommt, und der mit Abstand die beschissenste
Position im ganzen Haus hat, also der ist quasi halb hinter einer dicken Metallbox,
nämlich der Heizung, er ist maximal weit weg durch maximal weit Wände und halb hinter
einer Metallbox, deswegen mag das nicht, also deswegen muss ich den vielleicht tatsächlich
nochmal umpositionieren, wobei ich darauf echt keinen Bock habe, naja, aber was machst
du nicht alles, zumindest eine Sache ist auch schön, wenn man die Sachen mit einem Access
Point macht, ich mache keinen Repeater im Keller, das muss alles mit einem Access Point
abgefackelt werden, Repeater kommen wir nicht ins Haus, doch Müll, könnte man machen, könnte
man machen, aber das ist wirklich die, ja keine Ahnung, also unerwünschteste Sache,
ich meine ich habe sogar einen Raspberry Pi angeschlossen im Keller per Kabel, was bedeutet
ich könnte ohne Probleme im Keller da unten was repeaten, aber nee, nee, nee, das will
ich nicht, nee, dann stelle ich das Ding lieber unten ins Wohnzimmer oder so, ein Vorteil
von einem Access Point ist natürlich auch, dass man keine Probleme mit irgendwelchem
Roaming hat, das ist mittlerweile viel besser als früher, aber du hast halt keine Probleme
mehr, dass was abbricht, weil es ist immer der gleiche Access Point, gut, wie dem auch
sei genug über ein Access Point erzählt, das Ding ist wirklich nice, also das hat sich
gelohnt, das waren tatsächlich mal gut investierte 270 Euro auf Ebay und ich habe gesehen, dass
es aktuell tatsächlich sogar, weil letztens jemand gefragt hat, relativ günstig, also
nicht sowas hier, relativ günstig, welche gibt, und man kann die Dinger, wenn man will,
also ich würde bevorzugen es irgendwo aus EU zu bestellen, aber man kann auch die US
Dinger verwenden, weil man kann die Country unlocken, aber wie gesagt, Repeater habe
ich überhaupt keinen Bock drauf, wie gesagt, ich glaube das liegt nicht daran, dass der
Access Point zu schlecht ist, weil alles andere im Keller bekommt auch ganz gut Empfang, das
liegt glaube ich eher am ESP866, dass der nicht genug zurückschicken kann, bekommen
wird er die Signale vom Access Point, ich habe mal Iperf, ich habe mal der Gelegenheit gesehen,
es gibt sogar im Apple Store, es gibt sogar Iperf als App, war mir so gar nicht klar,
habe ich mal ordentliche Bandbreiten Tests gemacht, ich habe das Ding einfach auf 5 Minuten
eingestellt und wenn ich am Access Point stehe, habe ich ungefähr 300 MBit, 350 MBit maximal
und wenn ich dann runter laufe, die Treppe, Terrasse, sonst wie, da geht es natürlich
runter und ich kriege bis zum Garteneingang, kriege ich Empfang mit 7, 8 MBit, 11, 12 teilweise,
aber dann ist Schluss, was aber auch reicht, ich brauche im Garten keinen WLAN, Overrated,
Outdated, so, ok Leute, also was gucken wir uns jetzt an, zeichnet mal her, ich würde
sagen wir lassen uns erstmal Level Captchibaden, gucken wir dann, jetzt habe ich hier alles
für einen Krempel aufgemacht, Alter hör mal auf, ich will mich Level Captchibaden lassen
und wir müssen, wir machen mal kurz hier die ganzen Vorschau Dinge dazu, YouTube letzte
Straße, was zu empfehlen, he probably uninstalled this game after this time here, ah BO1, haha,
gekt, oh ok, das ist wirklich lucky as fuck gewesen, dass er das getroffen hat, also das
kommt nicht oft, das kam in dem Game nicht oft vor und hat auch noch sticky dran und
dann hat er doppelt zwei Leute auch noch gekillt, ja kommt vor, aber sehr selten, warum sind
die Ubiquiti Teile rausgeflogen bei dir, hat mehrere Gründe, ich weiß nicht ob wir da
einen Command für haben, haben wir da einen Command für, weiß nicht, zumindest, also
lange Rede kurzer Sinn, mir hat einiges nicht gefallen, aber das was für mich der ausschlaggebende
Punkt letztendlich war oder was alleine schon der ausschlaggebende Punkt wäre, unabhängig
von den anderen Sachen die mir nicht gefallen haben, dass Unify seit Jahren keinen Bock
hat zu implementieren, dass man unterschiedliche Passwörter pro Gerät vergeben kann und ich
rede nicht von WPA Enterprise, sondern dass man normale WLAN Passwörter pro Gerät vergeben
kann, das finde ich äußerst nützlich, gerade wenn man viele IOT Geräte hat die man auch
mal wegschmeißen will, weil ansonsten liegt das WLAN Passwort quasi mit dem Gerät im
Müll, vorausgesetzt man kann es nicht mehr überflaschen und selbst dann weiß ich nicht
ob das die Geräte alles auch richtig löschen oder so, also ich wollte unbedingt Passwörter
pro Geräte, das können die meisten WLAN Hersteller, die ein bisschen im teureren Segment
sind alle, mittlerweile kann es sogar TP Link mit ihrem Omada Unify Klon, aber Unify kann
es nicht und Ubiquiti hat ja auch keinen Bock drauf das einzubauen, gibt Feature Requests,
die sind 3-4 Jahre alt, haben massig Commons, aber Ubiquiti juckt es nicht und ich hatte
jetzt die Auswahl entweder ich Upgrade mein Ubiquiti Zeug mal auf Wifi 5, 6, weil da waren
ja teilweise noch richtig, da war noch der erste AC Pro und so dabei, nicht dass es zu
langsam gewesen wäre, aber ich hätte mal eh was Upgraden müssen, da hab ich mir gedacht
was war es, schmeißt den Scheiß raus, kauft ihr irgendwas ordentliches von Ebay und gut
ist, ist zwar eine Generation älter, macht aber nix, kann immer noch mehr und ist immer
noch schneller, kostet aber auch ein Access Point auf Ebay noch mehr als ein neuer Unify
Access Point, ich mein, wenn man sich mal die neuen Unify 6 Dinger ankostet, die kosten
200 Euro irgendwie den Dreh und ich hab 270, 260 Euro bezahlt für ein Access Point von
denen, also nicht von denen, von dem neuen Hersteller, 270 Euro auf Ebay gebraucht, letzte
Generation, also neu kosten die deutlich mehr, würde ich auch keinem empfehlen sich
das Ding neu zu kaufen, viel zu übertrieben, ich geb doch keine 1300 Euro für ein Access
Point aus, dann kauf ich lieber Generation ähm Generation älter und dann ist gut, nein
machts nicht, das wäre so, das wäre so, wenn du das mit Unify machen würdest, mit Unify
könntest du mehrere SSIDs aufmachen, könntest mehrere SSIDs mit unterschiedlichen Passwortern
aufmachen, aber maximal glaube ich auch nur 4 pro Access Point, das ist Müll und das
ist für die Signale wirklich nicht gut, ne was die machen ist, also implementieren alle
Hersteller ein bisschen anders, was die machen ist, dass auf einer SSID, letztendlich ist
das irgendeine Kombination aus, ja ich weiß es gar nicht genau, irgendwie eine Kombination
aus Sachen in der Access Point Firmware, die halt bei der Einwahl vom Gerät checkt, ist
das das richtige Passwort, das musst du dann halt gucken, ok, ist das einer der Keys und
nicht der einzige Netzwerkschlüssel und danach wird es gelockt an die MAC Adresse, aber erst
nach dem ersten Mal Login, was nicht schlimm ist, weil, naja du willst es ja eigentlich
nur für dieses eine Gerät verwenden und selbst wenn du es wegschmeißt, kannst du ja das Passwort
immer noch löschen und dann kann das Gerät selbst mit der richtigen MAC Adresse nicht
mehr rein, das ist alles auf der gleiche SSID, das ist ja das gute, das ist quasi ein bisschen
wie WPA Enterprise, ohne dass die Geräte WPA Enterprise unterstützen müssen, was kein
IoT Gerät kann, es gibt keine IoT Geräte oder so gut wie keine IoT Geräte, die WPA Enterprise,
wie nennt sich das eigentlich, korrekt, heißt das WPA Enterprise, ja, Radius heißt so,
naja, ok, IEEE 802.1x sowieso natürlich, alles klar, so, lassen wir uns mal eine Runde
level cap, jebaiten, jebaited, jebaited, auf gehts, da hat die Welt drauf gewartet, Moment,
Sekunde Leute, wo wir gerade dabei sind, das ist ja eingeschlagen wie die Bombe, diese
highly requested Dinger, ja, da hat ja jeder drauf gewartet und hat gesagt, jetzt spiel
ichs wieder, by the way, warum ist das Patch 4.1, 4.1 suggeriert doch in irgendeiner Art
und Weise, by the way, so gut sieht dieses Spiel niemals aus, suggeriert irgendwie,
dass Battlefield schonmal bei 1.0 war, Battlefield 2042, das ist Preview 4.1 vielleicht, ja,
also ich sag euch jetzt mal wie es ist, die Overwatch Alpha damals war von technischer
Seite her auf einem bedeutend besseren Level als Battlefield 2042 dreiviertel Jahr nach
oder ein halbes Jahr nach Release, ja, das ist 0.41 eher, natürlich kann man die zwei
Spiele jetzt vom Anzahl der Spiele und so nicht gut miteinander verkleiden, aber sind
beides Multiplayer Spiele und schon die Overwatch Alpha damals, die war so weich und hat sich
auch Netcode technisch super gespielt, da war gar nix an Problemen, ansonsten, eh, egal,
ich will mich jetzt nicht zu sehr über Overwatch auslassen, ich weiß immer noch nicht was
die zwei in Overwatch 2 rechtfertigt, aber ok, ja, das ist so, ist wirklich so, also
die Battlefield 3 Kampagne fand ich persönlich besser als die Battlefield 4 Kampagne, auch
wenn die Battlefield 3 Kampagne, ja, du darfst halt nicht, du darfst halt nicht abseits
der Hauptwege laufen oder gar irgendwo weiter hin wo das Spiel sagt, du darfst nicht hin,
dann ist das nicht sonderlich immersive die Battlefield 3 Kampagne, Battlefield 4 fand
ich nervig, Battlefield 4 war das einzige Battlefield im Singleplayer, wo ich so eine
Art Motion Sickness bekommen habe, weil das so wackelig war, aber ja, Battlefield 3 und
gerade Battlefield 4 sieht auch heute noch verdammt gut aus und die Maps und alles ist
einfach dreimal so detailliert, vergleich doch mal beispielsweise Siege of Shanghai versus,
da gab es doch ein schönes Bild, da gab es doch ein schönes Bild, da gab es doch ein
richtig schönes Vergleichsbild, ich glaube nicht, dass wir das jetzt noch finden, zumindest
er hat einen Screenshot gemacht von Siege of Shanghai und Kaleidoskop und du siehst
halt auf den ersten Blick, dass Siege of Shanghai laufend an jeder Ecke laufenden Band Details
hat, von Blättern die rum wehen, zu Zettel die an der Wand kleben, zu Sachen die wo rum
stehen und Kaleidoskop hat einfach nichts, gar nichts, das ist halt wirklich bitter,
so wir gucken jetzt das Video an, ich habe es 5 Sekunden geschafft schon 3 Minuten zu
reden, was könnte man eigentlich gerade spielen, schwierig, schwierig, also es gibt viele Leute,
die schwören aktuell auf so die bisschen realistischen Sachen, sowas wie Squad oder
so oder Hell and Loose und solche Dinger, kann ich wenig zu sagen, habe ich beides nicht
gespielt, habe ich mir alles gekauft auf Steam, aber meine Steam-Bibliothek besteht eh gefühlt
zu 80% aus Dingen, die ich mir wirklich gespielt habe, ja YouTube ist nicht so meins, Rainbow
Six Siege, naja hat jetzt ja mit Battlefield nicht so viel zu tun, so also gucken wir uns
das Video endlich mal an, da muss doch nichts revealed werden, man weiß doch eh schon das
wichtigste, was ist da dann Apex schon einmal schon wieder controversial, sag mal der bringt
doch in diesen Videos diese Battlefield News auch nur noch, weil die Leute das Memen wollen
oder, ansonsten es interessiert doch wirklich kein darf man sagen, kein Schwanz mehr oder
ist das zu sexistisch mittlerweile, es interessiert keine Sau mehr, sagen wir mal so, was die da
treiben in Battlefield 2042, man darf ja noch nicht erwarten, dass die Probleme gefixt
hätten, die es seit Release gibt, beispielsweise die Drohne im Portal Modus von Bad Company
2, die ist immer noch genauso beknackt wie bei Release, das hat keinen interessiert,
ich bin mir gar nicht mal sicher, ob es im Portal mittlerweile XP gibt, ich glaube das
geht mittlerweile.
Ja gut, das hat zwei Gründe, erstens es gibt nicht mehr genug Spieler und ein paar solchen
Spielmodus sieht man es, jetzt keine Sau spielt das mehr und Breakthrough 128 war von Anfang
an der mit Abstand beschissenste Spielmodus von diesem ganzen Ding, die Maps waren blatt,
Folge gestopft mit 128 Spielern, nichts auf der Map drauf was es spielbar macht mit 128,
nicht dass es mit 64 Spielern so viel besser wäre, aber kannst du das wirklich spielen?
Es ist 0.41, angeblich steht EA zum Verkauf, na Activision macht es vor, da bin ich mal
gespannt, das kann ich mir kaum vorstellen, aber das konnte man sich bei Activision auch
nicht vorstellen.
Ja das ist ja normal, gerade so die ultra hardcore rosa rote Brille Battlefield-Fans,
die es immer weniger gibt, aber immer noch ein paar, die finden immer irgendwas Positives
dran und wisst ihr, was so ein Argument ist, was mich mega abfuckt, wenn das einer bringt,
ich weiß jetzt wird der Chat das zu jeder Gelegenheit sagen und zwar, wenn man, sei
es in einem Forum oder in einem Video oder auf Steam oder sonst wie, wenn man irgendwas
kritisiert, wenn man zum Beispiel sagt, es ist eine schlechte Idee gewesen, dass du dir
beispielsweise in Battlefield 2042 Klassen machen kannst, die Snipern unendlich Ammo
haben und sich heilen können und sowas in der Richtung, also wenn du dir irgendwie sagst
das, warum macht man denn sowas, das ergibt doch eigentlich gar keinen Sinn, dann kommt
als Antwort, warum, du kannst das gar nicht beurteilen, mach es doch selber besser, dann
denke ich mir immer, Alter, PainsChamp, was ist das denn mal für eine Aussage, ich kann
auch was schlecht finden und das auch begründet schlecht finden, ohne, dass ich das skilltechnisch
from scratch selbst bauen könnte, das ist wie wenn ich mir, ich weiß nicht, in Deutschland
stehen wir auf Autovergleiche, das ist wie wenn ich mir ein Auto kaufe und der Sitz ist
unbequem, darf ich da nicht sagen, der Sitz ist unbequem, weil dann irgendjemand sagt,
jetzt bau doch erst mal selbst einen besseren Sitz, bevor du das ganze kritisierst, das
sind immer so Argumente, die sind so low IQ 3 hat, da fällt mir gar nichts mehr dazu
ein und das siehst du an allen Ecken und Enden, ich kann mich noch dran erinnern, das erste
Mal, wo mir so richtig aufgefallen ist, was die Leute für dummes Zeug schreiben, also
sinnloses Zeug, damals, als ich noch MMO gecriedete, es ist schon ewig her, es ist mir damals
schon aufgefallen, als ich MMO gecriedete, hab noch 24-7, da ging es immer darum, dass
die Webseite des MMO-Anbieters so schlecht zu benutzen ist, da hat mal einer einen riesen
Shitpost gemacht im offiziellen Forum, wie das denn sein kann, dass die Webseite so schlecht
ist und ich muss ihm recht geben, die Webseite ist schlecht und da gab es wirklich Leute,
die gesagt haben, so bringt das nicht, so bringt das nichts, mach eine, mach selbst erst mal
eine bessere Webseite und dann irgendwie schick es dem Hersteller, dass die sie nehmen können
oder so und da dachte ich, alter Leute, seid ihr so dumm oder seid ihr so weltfremd oder
seid ihr einfach nur bescheuert oder was ist los, das ist immer das beste Argument, mach
es doch selber erst mal besser, das heißt nicht, dass man einfach jetzt 30 Minuten so
vor dem Leder zieht und abgrundtief alles flamet, davon hat keiner was, aber wenn du
das als User, sagen wir mal halbwegs, auch wenn da die Emotionen teilweise mit einem
durchgehen, wenn man sich schon ewig auf ein Game gefreut hat, wenn man als User das halbwegs
fundiert, was kritisiert, man muss kein Spiel programmieren können, man ist User, man
spielt das Spiel, es gibt Aspekte, die einem nicht gefallen, so und wenn man diese Aspekte,
die einem nicht gefallen benennt, eventuell sogar noch, wenn man das kann, mit Verbesserungsvorschlägen
oder aber einfach nur sagt, das hat mir im alten Teil besser gefallen, zum Vergleich,
das reicht, derjenige, der das Spiel spielt, muss nicht in der Lage sein, ein besseres
Game zu programmieren, warum, er ist Konsument, er ist User, er ist kein Anbieter und Anbieter
tun gut daran, da drauf zu hören, natürlich kann man als Anbieter nicht immer auf alles
hören, was die Leute sagen, weil gerade wenn man sich offizielle Foren anguckt, das Geheule
ist teilweise unbegründet, unglaublich groß, man muss das filtern, deswegen finde ich es
auch unglaublich wichtig, dass Hersteller eben auf Leute hören, die Ahnung von dem Spiel
haben, also wenn ich ein Spiel machen würde, beziehungsweise wenn ich ein Spiel gemacht
hätte, was eine gewisse Bekanntheit erlangt, hat dann zu diesem Zeitpunkt, das erste was
ich machen würde ist, ich würde permanent, ich würde mir ein paar gute Leute raussuchen,
die das Spiel richtig gut spielen, am besten irgendwelche Semi-Pros oder Retired-Pro, wobei
Retired-Pros in einem neuen Spiel sind vielleicht ein bisschen schwierig, aber ihr wisst was
ich meine, also ich würde mir wirklich S-Tier-Spieler raussuchen und dann würde ich die bezahlen
dafür, dass die mit mir konstant Balance-Sachen besprechen und mich beraten, so wie das übrigens
Blizzard früher gemacht hat, die haben sich damals bei der Entwicklung zu World of Warcraft
haben die sich Top-Rate-Leute geholt, aus anderen Spielen, zum Beispiel aus Everquest,
Jeff, Overwatch-Jeff, hier, er hier, Papa Jeff von Overwatch, der war früher Top-Raider
in Everquest und den haben die sich geholt, damals für die Entwicklung von World of Warcraft
unter anderem, weil er ein so High-End-Tier-Everquest-Raider war und er wusste worauf es ankommt, also
ähnlich würde ich das auch machen, hätte ich wirklich ein Spiel, was gewissen Bekanntheitsgrad
hätte und ich möchte, dass es Balance ist, ich würde permanent, ich würde nicht diese
Blizzard-Taktik machen, so nach dem Motto, wir sitzen im stillen Kämmerlein, umgeben
uns mit Leuten, die uns permanent Zucker in den Arsch blasen und dann denken, alles ist
fein oder so, wie DICE das bei Battlefield 2042 gemacht hat, ich habe es ja schon oft
gesagt, also auf diesen Anspiel-Events, das war so ein krasses Rumgeschleime die ganze
Zeit, unglaublich, nicht alle, aber das, gerade im englischsprachigen Bereich, also das was
man gelesen hat, so nach dem Motto, ihr habt da wirklich was am Laufen, ihr habt da was
richtig, wo ich mir gedacht habe, Alter, das erste was mir aufgefallen ist, als ich das
Spiel gespielt habe, das erste was ich gesehen habe, ich weiß noch, das erste was ich gesehen
habe, als ich in diesem Anspiel-Events, das erste Mal, als ich in diesem Anspiel-Events
in das Game gegangen bin, das erste was ich gesehen habe, ich bin gespawnt, habe in die
Luft geguckt und habe einen Jet gesehen, der so geflogen ist, Leute, so, das hier, das
hier ist der Jet, so, der Jet ist so geflogen, habe ich gedacht, das kann doch nicht gewollt
sein, das ist das erste was ich gesehen habe, als ich jemals in Battlefield 2042 reingespawnt
bin, der sich total beschissen, unrealistisch bewegt hat und habe ich mir gedacht, was ist
da los?
Aber die Leute voll am ausflippen im Discord, oh, ist das toll, you got onto something oder
was auch immer, na gut, was auch immer, zumindest, so würde ich das machen, ich würde mir Leute
besorgen, nee, muss ich nicht aktive Pros sein, die wirklich gut in dem Spiel sind und
mit denen würde ich permanent Balanced Sachen besprechen und ich würde mein Spiel, wenn
es ein Multiplayer-Spiel ist, ich würde mein Spiel von Grund auf so bauen, dass ich, wie
sagt man so schön heutzutage, continuous deployment, also dass ich kontinuierlich neue
Updates pushen kann, natürlich kannst du nicht alle Updates pushen, ja, gerade wenn
du kleinen Updates brauchst, geht das nicht, aber ich würde das so aufbauen, dass du Server
Updates immer pushen kannst, das geht ja mittlerweile in Battlefield 2042 halbwegs, soweit ich das
mitbekommen habe und vor allem, dass ich Balance-Änderungen immer machen kann, also Änderungen, die nichts
erfordern, außer das Ändern von irgendwelchen Zahlen oder von irgendwelchen, ja, Zahlen
im Endeffekt, von Timern, von Damage-Werten, von irgendwelchen solchen Sachen, das muss
on the fly passieren, können, ja, also du musst sagen können, Mist, ich hab Mist gebaut,
was weiß ich, das Schild von Held A hat ja irgendwie viel zu viele Punkte in Kombination
mit der Sache aus von B, ja, dann patchen wir das mal kurz irgendwie so und dann hast
du nämlich den großen Vorteil, wenn du das machen kannst, wenn du die Sachen patchen
kannst, ohne 3 Monate zu brauchen, dann hast du den Vorteil, dass du auch mal, ähm, vielleicht
eine Anpassung machen kannst, die ein bisschen zu viel ist, aber dann kannst du relativ
schnell iterieren und das Ganze auf ein sinnvolles, gut spielbares Level packen, ja, ansonsten
hast du das übliche, ich hab's ja schon oft gezeigt, ansonsten hast du das übliche Blizzard,
Blizzard Balancing und Blizzard Balancing wissen wir alle, sieht im Endeffekt, sieht
im Endeffekt so aus, so, irgendwie Held X kommt raus, ja, das ist hier, das ist OP und
das hier ist Suck, so und was weiß ich, Game kommt raus und Blizzard Balancing mit Held
ist halt das hier, so Held ist OP, Held ist OP, Held ist OP, 3 Monate später kommt ein
Patch, Held ist absolut useless, absolut useless, absolut useless, so dann werden alle anderen
Helden gepatcht oder was auch immer, so und dann irgendwann rework, rework von Helden,
dann ist der noch OPer als am Anfang, so und dann wird er, dann wird er vielleicht genervt
und ist dann komplett wieder useless, also das hier, das hier ist Blizzard Balancing,
so, so funktioniert das und da würd ich alles dran setzen, dass das in dem Spiel, wo ich
entwickeln, was ich nicht mache, weil ich keine Ahnung von Spielentwicklern, dran setzen
würde, dass man das etwas weicher handhaben kann, ja, das muss on the fly gehen und das
in Kombination mit Leuten, die Ahnung vom Spiel haben, ich bin der Meinung, wenn du
wirklich ein Competitive Spiel basteln musst, basteln, nicht basteln, basteln willst, dann
muss das vor allem, das muss natürlich Competitive auf allen Leveln sein, aber es muss vor allem
sich dadurch auszeichnen, dass es Competitive oder Balanced ist auf dem absoluten Top Level,
also Balanced auf S Tier Niveau muss das ganze sein, der Rest kommt von allein, weil anders,
anders kannst du ja schlecht was balancen, also wie möchtest du was balancen, willst
du es balancen für die, sagen wir so, 90% der Player Base, die nicht gut ist und dann
kannst, hast du nichts, was ordentlich funktioniert, High Level und alle spielen das gleiche, ich
bin der Meinung, wenn du für S Tier balancest, kommt das andere nach und nach, so und Hauptsache
on the fly, gut, was auch immer, lange Rede, kurzer Sinn, ja, ihr sagt doch, das ist Blizzard
Battle, das ist bei allem so, das ist bei allem was die machen so, DLCs Heroes sind
am Anfang OP, weil die Leute DLCs verkaufen wollen, ja genau, sowas ist das, bei Destiny
machen sie es mittlerweile auch so, ja, so musst du es ja eigentlich auch machen, weil
die Entwickler, die sind, wenn die ihr eigenes Spiel spielen, da habe ich so meine Zweifel,
ob die das machen, aber wenn die Entwickler selbst ihr Spiel spielen, die sind schon
ganz brauchbar mit der Zeit in ihrem Game, wenn man das die Entwicklung überspielt, aber
die sind halt nicht so gut, wie beispielsweise wirkliche Semi-Pros in irgendwelchen FPS Games
oder halt irgendwelche Leute, die explizit sich da Spaß dran haben, quasi irgendwelche
unbalanced Kombinationen zu finden und deswegen, warum sollte man diese Leute bekämpfen,
sondern man sollte sie besser auf die eigene Seite holen und sagen, man sollte die übrigens
auch bezahlen, ja, ich habe in ganz vielen MMOs gesehen, dass es irgendwelche, wie nennt
man das, Volontär, ehrenamtlich, ehrenamtlich, dass es irgendwelche ehrenamtliche Programme
gibt, so nach dem Motto, ja, es gibt jetzt hier den ehrenamtlichen, sagen wir mal, was
weiß ich, irgendwie Krieger-Community, also ich Commander, Krieger oder sagen wir mal
so, Assassin-Community-Lied oder nee, nicht Community, wie heißt das, irgendwie den,
was weiß ich, Community-Ansprechpartner für Class X, Y, ehrenamtlich, habe ich in ganz
vielen MMOs gesehen, sowas in der Richtung und dann hast du Leute, die stecken da wirklich
so viel Zeit rein und so viel Energie und Geld und Zeit in dieses MMO und schreiben
für den Hersteller wirklich Berichte umsonst, so nach dem Motto, so Eindruck von der Klasse,
wie es aktuell da ist, wie es Balancing ausschaut versus andere Klassen, Listenskills auf was
du machen sollst und der Hersteller scheißt komplett drauf, ja, wo ich immer wieder erstaunt
bin, dass das Leute tatsächlich ehrenamtlich immer noch machen und sich dann auch noch
abspeisen lassen mit Eins-Heilern im Endeffekt, also ich würde die Leute tatsächlich bezahlen
dafür, gerade wenn du irgendwelche Semi-Pros hast, die sind natürlich darauf angewiesen
auch, dass sie davon leben können und ja, egal, so weiter, Video, fertig, Dead by Daylight
Balance nicht vertoppt hier und zieht dadurch viele Probleme, ich wusste gar nicht, dass
Dead by Daylight irgendwie Competitive ist, ja, StarCraft 1 hatte aber auch, ich glaube
bei StarCraft 1 sind ein paar Sachen zusammengekommen, erstens, dass die Leute damals bei Blizzard
ihr Game selber rauf und runter gespielt haben, das war bei StarCraft 2 teilweise noch so,
der StarCraft 2 Multiplayer Balance Typ ist ja wohl eines der besten Random-Spieler, war
wohl einer der besten Random-Spieler der Welt, also der war wohl richtig gut, auch in der
Korea, Leather und sowas, das war kein Kacknoop, aber ich glaube in StarCraft 1 kamen mehrere
Sachen zusammen, erstens, dass die wirklich Leute hatten, die den Kram selber stundenweise
am Tag gegrindet haben und ein paar glückliche Fügungen zusammen und dass damals diese ganze
koreanische Geschichte losgegangen ist und die Koreaner haben diesen Kram irgendwie selbst
gebalanced, das kann man schwer beschreiben, ich hab mir mal ein Video drüber angeguckt,
die Entwicklung von StarCraft, also von eSport Play StarCraft 1 und da hast du richtig gesehen,
es gab Dinger, die galten als gnadenlos OP und da kam dann irgendwie ein super krasser
Five Head Koreaner und hat gesagt, ne, das stimmt überhaupt nicht, wenn man das anders
spielt ist das andere viel besser, also wenn man das ordentlich spielt aus koreanischer
Sicht heißt, 350 APM, 100 Sachen gleichzeitig machen, aber wenn man das richtig macht,
dann ist das andere eigentlich mehr OP und dann haben die Koreaner gesagt, ok, das ist
dann doch gar nicht so schlecht, die Klasse oder in Kombination oder Units, die sonst
keiner verwendet hat, waren auf einmal gut und dann kam der nächste Six Head Koreaner
und hat gesagt, haha, aber wenn man das noch anders macht und dann irgendwie mit 5000 APM
spielt und quasi mit den Füßen auch gleichzeitig tippt, dann ist das andere wieder besser,
also irgendwie haben die Koreaner StarCraft 1 untereinander gebalanced mit noch immer
mehr Five Head Plays, ja, da musst du Blizzard an StarCraft 1 gar nicht so viel machen, ne,
was auch immer, also da kamen ein paar glückliche Sachen zusammen, aber da hat man auch gesehen,
StarCraft 1 muss halt auch für Top Tier balanced, so, jetzt gucken wir uns aber endlich das
Video an.
Was für ein Programm benutzt du, um deine Fotos zu bearbeiten?
Ich benutze hier Affinity Designer und Foto für meine Thumbnails.
Ach ja, Micro Stuttering, ich wusste gar nicht, dass das Spiel Micro Stuttering, ich dachte,
es hat generell Stuttering.
In Lune.
Meinung zu World War 3, ganz im Ernst, ich hab das gespielt, ja, ok, also für das, dass
es wohl ein ziemlich kleines Entwicklerstudio ist, alles ok, aber ich sehe das Spiel nicht
vorauskommen.
Vor allem, ich werde es nie wieder installieren, solange es Mail.ru als Anti-Cheat verwendet.
Oh, vier Maps, unglaublich, ein halbes Jahr nach Release werden vier neue Maps erwähnt
in den Spielefiles, können ihr euch das vorstellen?
Erwähnt, nicht etwa reingepatcht, nein, die werden erwähnt irgendwo in den Spielefiles,
also sprich, wir haben jetzt ein halbes Jahr ohne jeglichen Content, obwohl das Spiel eigentlich
ein Service Game sein soll, das kann man sich nicht ausmalen, das kann man sich nicht ausmalen,
oder?
Ein halbes Jahr ohne Content in einem Service Game, von was für einem Service reden die
da eigentlich?
Das ist eigentlich BF2.0 Season 1 Start, wann ist denn das, ok, also Anfang Juni Start,
das ist ja nicht mehr so viel, Mail.ru Anti-Cheat, jaja, die haben Mail.ru, also nicht Battlefield,
World War 3 hat Mail.ru Anti-Cheat, ok, kann ich, Steam, Alter, jetzt krieg ich das alles
auf Russisch, weil ich Mail.ru gesucht hab, oder was?
Welt im Krieg 3, ist alles klar, es ist Mail.ru Anti-Cheat, das will ich nicht haben.
Ist das gut oder schlecht, das ist schlecht, ich will kein Mail.ru Anti-Cheat haben, ok,
warum, das ist eine gute Frage, also erstens möchte ich generell ungern Anti-Cheat haben,
weil sich quasi als Root-Kits im System einnistet, das ist leider das Problem bei vielen Anti-Cheats,
die Sache ist nur die, ich traue den normalen Anti-Cheats schon nicht, und ich traue einem
China-Chinesen Tencent Anti-Cheat oder einem Mail.ru Anti-Cheat noch weniger, und irgendwann
ist diese Linie überschritten, wo ich sag, ich installier's mir nicht, ich bin schon
kein Fan von normalen Root-Kit-Style Anti-Cheat drauf zu hauen, aber bei mir ist bei China-Chinesen
und EU Anti-Cheat, oder falls es nordkoreanischen Anti-Cheat gibt, keine Ahnung, dann insofern
überschritten, dass ich mir das gar nicht installiere, ob die jetzt wirklich damit mehr
krome Dinge anstellen, wie beispielsweise der Valorant Anti-Cheat, ob die mehr krome Dinge
anstellen als beispielsweise Apex mit ihrem Root-Kit-Style Anti-Cheat, weiß man natürlich
nicht, aber ich traue denen da mehr zu, im negativen Sinn, d.h. Mail.ru Anti-Cheat hab
ich wirklich keinen Bock drauf.
Ich muss das ja immer wieder sagen, das hat mich schon das erste Mal, als ich das gesehen
hab, getriggert, wo ich immer nicht verstehe, warum, ich hab's 500 Mal in diesem Trailer
schon gesagt, warum läuft die auf die Motorhaube, um in das Auto reinzuschießen? Das ist doch
einfach nur, dass es cooler aussieht, oder? Möchte die von dem Auto umgefahren werden,
oder möchte die, kann die von vorne nicht durchschießen, oder warum will die ein besonders
gutes Ziel abgeben, wenn sie aufs Auto klettert? Ich versteh's nicht, das hab ich beim Reveal-Trailer
damals schon gedacht, warum klettert die aufs Auto, um da reinzuschießen? Ja, das ist schwierig
zu sagen, Chet, weil, das kann man schwer sagen, ich mein nur, weil es viele Attacken
gibt, die irgendwie aus Richtung China oder aus Richtung Russland ausgehen, also Absender-IP
technisch, muss es nicht zwangsläufig, also ich trau das denen auf jeden Fall zu, sowohl
den Chinesen als auch den Russen, muss es aber ja nicht zwangsläufig bedeuten, dass
die eigentlichen Angreifer auch dort zugehörig sind. Ich hab letztens beispielsweise gelesen
in irgendeinem Artikel, dass wohl VPNs, ich glaube nach im Iran oder so, recht beliebt
sind für irgendwelche Hacker-Sachen neuerdings. Ich glaub bei Hacker-News irgendwo hab ich
das gelesen, dass jetzt gerade iranische VPNs bei Hackern voll angesagt sind. Ich wusste
bis dahin gar nicht, dass es im Iran VPN-Anbieter gibt, aber anscheinend ist das so. Ich frag
mich immer noch, wie man Apex auf Mobile mit, also das ist ja ein relativ schnelles Game,
wie man das auf Mobile gescheit spielt. Ich krieg ja, ich hab ja schon Anfälle bekommen
bei normalen Mobile-Games mit der Touchscreen-Steuerung und dann Apex. Wahrscheinlich kannst du eh
wieder cheaten mit nem Emulator und Maus und Tastatur oder Controller. Naja gut, also
komm, man muss es jetzt mal nicht übertreiben. Es gibt bei uns sicherlich Sachen, gerade
wenn man sich so Dinge anguckt wie von Chat-Kontrolle bis wir müssen immer mehr einschränken, die
meiner Meinung nach auch in die falsche Richtung gehen, aber von du wirst in den Arbeitslager
gesteckt oder verschwindest von der Bildfläche, wenn du was falsches sagst oder wirst vergiftet
oder sonst was oder wirst gar erschossen, sind wir ja noch ein bisschen weiter entfernt,
was ja auch ganz gut ist.
Also sprich undelayed bedeutet, man hat das Delay wieder rückgängig gemacht, also es
erscheint wie geplant.
Übrigens, wisst ihr was ich auch nicht so genau verstehe, ist nicht Witcher 3 seit Release
schon Next-Gen auf dem PC, also warum brauche ich eine Next-Gen Fassung von dem was ich
auf dem PC seit 8 Jahren oder 10 Jahren oder wann kam das raus, das ist eine Weile her,
also ich habe mich mit dem Remaster nicht großartig beschäftigt, aber was cool wäre
auf jeden Fall, wenn die die ganzen NPC Models ein bisschen vielfältiger machen würden.
Dafür habe ich auch noch, also es gibt Mods, die tauschen Charaktere aus, aber ich habe
noch keinen Mod gesehen, wenn ihr da einen kennt, würde mich echt interessieren, der
die NPCs vielfältiger macht, also es gibt Mods, die die NPC Models verbessern, aber es
ist trotzdem so, dass wenn du in Witcher 3, sagen wir mal, 10 Quests machst, davon haben
die Hälfte der Quests die gleichen NPCs mit unterschiedlichem Hercut, wenn es hoch
kommt, also die Haare der NPCs sehen dann ein bisschen anders aus, aber das Gesicht
und das Model ist mehr oder weniger das gleiche.
Also wenn es da einen Mod gäbe, der vielleicht aus 30 verschiedenen NPC Models dies gibt,
60 verschiedene NPC Models machen würde, das wäre nice, wobei ich mir vorstellen könnte,
dass das Mod technisch gar nicht geht, da bin ich mir aber nicht sicher, weil ja in
dem Game selbst wahrscheinlich Hardcoded ist, welche NPC welche Model ID hat und wenn das
Hardcoded ist, dass die einfach nur 30, 40 verschiedene Models da verteilt haben, kannst
du nicht einfach 60 Models machen für random NPCs, ohne die komplette Gamewelt durchzugehen
und das zu, oder man randomisiert das irgendwie, keine Ahnung, also das würde für mich Witcher
3 nochmal auf Next Level bringen, wenn man die NPCs etwas besser verteilt, dass es nicht
immer die gleichen sind.
Ich auch nicht, keine Ahnung, ich weiß es nicht, ich hab mir das auch noch nicht angeguckt.
Okay, Witcher 3 Next Gen Update, zeig mal.
Difference, Difference, okay, also Zeig her, Difference, eh, irgendwas mit Raytracing,
okay, also in jedem Fall Raytracing juckt mich so überhaupt nicht, Loading Times ist
gut, ja wie das war's, reddit, reddit, wir fragen reddit, reddit, reddit, reddit weiß
bei sowas immer Bescheid, reddit ist high IQ, was ist der Unterschied, nix oder, man
weiß es nicht, vielleicht weiß die GameStar was dazu, ne, was bringt das denn, sich für
Konsolenbesitzer spannend, das ist alles, ich kauf, ich kauf mir doch nicht wirklich,
ich kauf mir doch nicht das Spiel nochmal neu, weil ich da irgendwie Raytracing kann
drin, ist das hier nicht sogar schon raus, man bekommt irgendeinen Witcher Skin oder
irgendwas, es gibt keine neue Story Mission glaube, haben sie doch irgendwo mal gesagt,
naja, weiß nicht, man muss es nicht neu kaufen, sicher, sicher, das wär cool, Price, Price,
ah, das ist gut, das finde ich nice, aber dann bedeutet das im Umkehrschluss auch, dass
sich wirklich an Inhalten nicht viel ändern wird, also wenn du das, wenn die ein Free
Update geben wird, dann wird sich der Inhalt nicht so viel tun, so, haben wir das Video
heute irgendwann nochmal geschafft, Alter, die Witcher Serie, das hat so, egal, da hab
ich mich schon oft genug darüber ausgelassen, das Spiel hat doch zeitgemäße Grafik, also
ich finde ganz ehrlich, Witcher 3, ok, ja, du kannst natürlich immer noch ein paar Sachen
drehen, gerade mit den Sachen, die du in den letzten Jahren an Techniken dazu bekommen
hast, ja, aber vieles ist ja, ohne das grundsätzlich neue Assets reinzubringen und da Sachen umzuprogrammieren
gar nicht möglich, also du kannst ja nur so viel machen, wie du machen kannst, ohne dass
du viel Hand anlegen musst an das Game, deswegen glaube ich auch nicht, dass da viel kommt,
also das ist irgendwie, die werden ein bisschen höhere auflösenden Texturen machen, ja,
die werden vielleicht ein bisschen bessere Models machen, aber so Sachen wie das, was
ich mir beispielsweise wünschen würde, dass nicht jeder dritte, vierte NPC gleich aussieht,
das wäre mal cool, ja, das, das, das wäre wirklich, das wäre wirklich Pog.
Wildwildwitcher 3 auf der Switch, das ist das hässlichste Game ever, alter, sieht so
mies aus.
Was hältst du von Microsoft Zertifizierung oder auch anderen Zertifikaten wie CCNA?
Ja, kann man machen, ich fand's immer ein bisschen Zeitverschwendung und Geldverschwendung
je nachdem, ob es dein Arbeitgeber bezahlt oder nicht.
Es ist sicherlich nicht verkehrt, also gerade im Netzwerkumfeld sind diese Cisco-Dinger
tatsächlich relativ angesehen, ich meine CCNA nicht wirklich, CCNA, ich, sogar ich
habe einen CCNA, der ist aber mittlerweile abgelaufen und ich habe wirklich keinen großartigen
Plan von Cisco Netzwerkgeräten und also beim CCNA kommst du nicht sonderlich weit, das
zeigt höchstens, du hast grundsätzliche Ahnung von Netzwerkgeschichten.
Die höherwertige Zertifizierung, ja, die sind sicherlich, denke ich, relativ gefragt,
wenn du Netzwerksachen machst, gerade Cisco Zertifizierung, ich kann es dir aber nicht
aus erster Hand sagen, ich weiß aber, dass die höheren Cisco Zertifizierungen nicht
ohne sind.
Ein Kollege von mir damals hat den Cisco Internet Engineer oder wie heißt dieses Ding?
Das Cisco Internet Engineer oder wie heißt das höchste Ding, was die haben?
Hat jemand eine Ahnung davon?
Internet Expert ist es?
Was ist CCIE?
Internet Work Expert, ich habe keine Ahnung, ob das das war, ich bilde mir aber ein, dass
der irgendwas gemacht hat in Richtung Internet Engineer, aber das ist das glaube ich, ja,
das ist aber auch schon überlegen, das war noch, wo ich beim Provider gearbeitet habe,
das war 2011 oder so wahrscheinlich und das war nicht ohne, aber der Typ war eh krass
drauf, der hat da in seiner Freizeit für gelernt und hat dann den, ist Cisco nicht eine private
Firma?
Doch, klar ist es, der hat da irgendwie privat für gelernt und hat dann seinen Chef damals
beschwätzt, dass er die Zertifizierung machen darf und der hat die beim ersten Anlauf easy,
okay zeig mal her, wie viele Zertifizierungen, oh, was zum, Monka, was, Alter, gut, das gibt
es mittlerweile in verschiedenen Ausprägungen oder was?
Du kannst CCNA in unterschiedlichen Sachen machen, also als ich CCNA gemacht habe, das
ist wie gesagt auch schon eine Weile her, da kann ich mir nicht dran erinnern, dass
es dort, dass es den CCNA in verschiedenen Ausprägungen gab, weil, also wir haben Routing
und Switching gemacht, wir haben ein bisschen Security gemacht, ein bisschen Wireless gemacht,
gibt nur noch CCNA, vielleicht CCN-End, warum sollte Cisco keine Zertifizierung anbieten,
das ist ja quasi so ein eigener Kosmos zum Geldmachen Zertifizierung, vielleicht ist das
auch nur so ein Querschnitt, der sagt, es gibt ein CCNA, nee, es gibt noch ein CCDA,
was zum, okay, keine Ahnung, ich bin mir, weil jemand im Chat gesagt hat, das ist in
Deutschland, gibt es das nicht mehr, also ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass der irgendwas
mit Internetengineer, da gibt es nur den, also ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass der Kollege
damals das gemacht hat, aber wenn es das in Deutschland nicht gibt, vielleicht war es
auch das, aber ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass es das hier war, ja, aber ansonsten ich
bin kein großartiger Zertifikate-Fan, weil ganz im Ernst das meiste, was man in der
Archive macht, sind eh irgendwelche, ja, das, was es schwierig macht, sind unternehmensspezifische
Wirrungen, ja, und da bringt einem ein Zertifikat nichts, zum Beispiel, wenn ich jetzt, naja,
mal angenommen, ich bin jetzt Zertifizierter Exchange-Administrator, falls es so was gibt,
wahrscheinlich gibt es so was, und ich nehme jetzt einen Job an, wo ich mich um E-Mails
kümmern muss, allerdings, es ist Postfix, also ist es schön und gut, dass ich weiß,
wie ich mit E-Mails, was ich mit E-Mails machen muss, aber, wobei, das war noch nicht die
halbe, nein, nur die halbe, es ist Postfix, plus irgendwelche unternehmensspezifischen
Datenbank-Gedingse im Hintergrund, dann bringt mir das nichts, und selbst wenn ich mich
mit Linux und Postfix auskenne, heißt das nicht zwangsläufig, dass ich mich mit diesem
Setup auskenne, und die meisten, die ein bisschen Ahnung haben, sag mal, wenn du jemand
hast, der sich mit Linux ganz gut auskennt, der kommt relativ schnell rein, wie der irgendeine
Mailgeschichten aus Postfix und sonstigen Sachen administriert, kompliziert ist dann
die unternehmensspezifische Implementierung und was die sich da so vorstellen, und das
bringt dir keine Zertifizierung der Welt, das lernst du erst dort vor Ort und bringt
dir meistens auch nur dort was.
Also das wichtigste, den wichtigsten Skill, den man in der IT haben muss, ist genug Wissen,
dass man weiß, nach was man suchen muss, und genug Wissen, dass man mit Hilfe von Suchen
und Nachlesen relativ schnell in Themen, wo man keine Ahnung von hat, reinkommt.
Ansonsten, weiß nicht, da bringen am Zertifizierung aber wenig.
Es bringt einem natürlich schon was, ich will damit nicht sagen, dass man sich in keinem
Bereich auskennen soll, letztendlich dort, wofür man bezahlt wird, ist ja seine Expertise
bzw. das Gebiet, je nachdem wie gefragt ist, wovon man Ahnung hat, also wenn die jetzt
irgendwie wirklich einen Senior, keine Ahnung,.NET Developer suchen, dann bringt es nichts,
wenn du sagst, ja ich habe C-Sharp schon mal verwendet, aber ich kann mich schnell einarbeiten.
Ich glaube, das wird wahrscheinlich keinen überzeugen.
Aber, was du nicht können musst, ist, irgendwelche unternehmensspezifischen Libraries und Helper
Sachen und Dinger, und Datenbank Schemas und was auch immer, die die da programmiert haben,
da musst du dich dann schnell einarbeiten können, und da bringt es dir gar nichts, dass
du irgendeine Microsoft.NET Zertifizierung hast.
So, also was soll ich mir jetzt angucken, Entry Associate Specialist Professional Expert,
Professional Approach, ok, die haben das ein bisschen zusammengestaucht alles, es gibt
bloß noch ein CCNA, aber es gibt mehrere Experts, und das Zeug ist auch teuer.
Du spielst The Link to the Past Randomizer, spielst du manchmal irgendwo mit?
Ich gucke mir ganz gerne Streams an, ich bin das äußerst beruhigend.
So, ich rolle jetzt mal durch und dann, kann es sein, dass wir das erste Level Cap Video
immer noch nicht geschafft haben nach über einer Stunde?
Es ist ja heute wieder Wahnsinn, Alter, ok, jetzt haben wir endlich fertig geguckt, wir
haben drei Minuten Video geguckt in 45 Minuten oder so, keck, wie schlecht, ich sollte doch
ins Reaction-Business gehen, ne?
Ich finde übrigens Reforger ein unglaublich schlechter Name, erstens erinnert mich das
sehr an Warcraft 3 Reforged und Reforger klingt irgendwie holprig, was wird denn da neu geschmiedet?
Also ich hab das Spiel gestern oder so mal kurz beim Lost im Stream geguckt und das sah
nicht ansatzweise so gut aus wie hier.
Aber ich glaube, dass die Spieler auf die neuen Game Engine Tools haben werden, wenn
Arma 4 aufbaut.
According to Industry Insider Jeff Grubb, Star Wars Jedi Survivor, ist die sehr erwartete
Relektion von Fallen Order.
According Grubb wird es im Mai und im nächsten Jahr entdeckt.
Grubb hat auch gesagt, dass Cal Kestis aus dem ersten Spiel noch der Hauptprotagonist ist.
Der Bespin Bulletin, Star Wars News Outlet, hat aber eine konflikte Information.
Sie glauben, das Spiel wird zwischen zwei unterschiedlich spielbaren Charakteren geteilt.
Fans spekulieren, wir könnten als sowohl Cal als auch ein möglicher Padawan spielen.
Beide Sourcen sind sicher, Details werden bei Star Wars Celebration entdeckt.
In anderen Star Wars News, ein Patch ist live für Lego Star Wars The Skywalker Saga.
Die Entwickler von TT Games haben gemerkt, dass die genaue Verbesserung der Stabilität
und Leistung des Spiels gemacht worden sind.
Neue Kapitelschiffe wurden mit zusätzlichen, erheblichen Itens, die in der Spielwelt
hängen.
Die Spieler sind zufrieden mit dem Patch, obwohl sie denken, mehr sollte gemacht werden,
um die Probleme mit der Freeplay-Mode zu handeln.
Diese Mode hat viele beängstigende Buggen, z.B. unvergessliche Progressionen und Spiele-Kraschen.
TT Games haben noch nicht gemerkt, dass die genaue Verbesserung der Stabilität und Leistung
der Stabilität und Leistung des Spiels gemacht worden sind.
Wer hätte das auch gedacht?
Ein Patch, der nicht mehr kaputt macht.
Die Entwickler von TT Games haben aber versichert, dass sie sich um das Spiel weiterentwickeln
wollen.
In einer Entwickler-Update hat Bungie die nächste Dungeon von Destiny 2 geteilt.
Ich habe da mal eine Frage, und zwar, was ich nicht ganz verstehe, ist, oder zumindest
wie das für mich als Außenstehender wirkt, wenn man Destiny verfolgt, dass es in Destiny
eigentlich gar nicht durchgehend was zu tun gibt.
Also du kannst quasi Destiny spielen, dann spielst du das ein paar Tage, bzw. am Anfang
auch ein paar Wochen, wenn du noch hinterher bist, aber sagen wir mal so, du bist auf Endgame
Niveau und bist Endgame equipped.
So, dann kommt ein neuer Patch, dann spielst du den vielleicht eine Woche, und dann bist
du mit dem Patch durch, und dann wartest du quasi wieder drei Monate bis der nächste
Patch kommt.
Oder?
So wirkt das auf mich, wenn ich mir das, ja du kannst Destiny alle drei Monate eine Woche
spiele, dann ist Ende.
Ja, so wirkt das auf mich auch.
Das einzige, was man glaube ich machen muss, ist sich daily einloggen und bei diesem Daily
Shop immer regelmäßig buyen, aber ansonsten?
Gears of War Series wird dieses Jahr eine Master Chief Collection Remaster bekommen.
Also mit dünn meine ich nicht die Muskeln, weißt was ich meine, also das ist der langweiligste
Actionheld Character ever, also keine Ahnung, man merkt, dass sie irgendwas versucht haben
wollen, aber das hat nicht, keine Ahnung, also ich werde mit den Gears of War Characters
nicht warm, wobei ich sagen muss, das erste Gears of War fand ich richtig gut, gerade
im Koop, das ist eines der nicesten Koop Spiele überhaupt, danach weniger, aber das erste
war richtig gut.
Und außerdem, es geht so vor, das einzige Spiel hier einen Charakter an der Bert heißt,
und ich weiß, dass man ihn nicht so schreibt, aber Bert.
Ist das nicht, ist das nicht das Spiel, also wo er den Trailer von zeigt?
Ist das nicht das, was er machen wollte und dann mit dem Hauptdarsteller doch jetzt, also
nachdem er sich da mit Konami irgendwie verkracht hat oder so, woran, dass er dann den DHL Simulator
mit dem gleichen Hauptdarsteller rausgebracht hat, also Death Stranding, ich mein, ok, es
gab einen Mini Patch, der Mini Sachen geändert hat, Yala Spiel ist in einem besseren State
als vorher, das heißt aber noch lange nicht, dass es in einem State ist, dass man das
spielen will, was, was, ja gut, das liegt wahrscheinlich daran, weil keiner eine PS5 liefern kann, warum?
Ja, es gibt keine gescheiten Games, ja gut, das kann man immer, ok, daran wird es nämlich
auch liegen, das ist das, was ich mir gerade gedacht habe, wahrscheinlich ist einfach
keine PS5 lieferbar und dementsprechend sind die PS5 Zahlen so schlecht, dass die normalen
Xbox Zahlen einfach besser sind.
Ich hab übrigens immer noch keinen Plan, warum man sich die Xbox kaufen sollte aktuell,
ich weiß auch beide nicht, warum man sich die PS5 kaufen sollte aktuell, also ich hab
keine und ich werd mir auch keine kaufen, ich hab mir die letzte Konsolengeneration
zu Release gekauft, wurde einmal hart gebated mit der Zwischenkonsolen Release Version,
obwohl ich schon zum Release der letzten Konsolengeneration gesagt hab, die Dinger sind eigentlich
gemessen, an dem was drin steckt, zum Release Zeitpunkt viel zu schwach, das haben die Hersteller
auch so gesehen, haben dann nochmal ein Update verkauft, was ich mir nie gekauft hab und
ich hab die Konsolen, keine Ahnung, 10 Minuten, äh ne 10 Stunden, jede vielleicht angehabt
die letzten paar Jahre über, komplett useless, absolut useless, rausgeschmissenes Geld ever.
So, was ist das, Record Chatsuit Mountain, warum genau wurde mir dieses Video vorhin
vorgeschlagen?
Ok Sekunde, muss ich mir jetzt angucken, das ist Tross Musik, how fast can a medic ascend,
was, hell villain, 3100 Fuß, geht das vielleicht auch in ordentlichen 944 Meter, das ist ja
gerade mal der Feldberg bei uns um die Ecke, Frankfurt Feldberg, der ist Höhe, ok 831
alles klar, ah ungefähr, das ist ja nicht so viel, ok zeig her, Pog, ich frag mich ob
so ein Ding, bis zu wieviel Kilo so ein Ding geht, also ich hab neues Record Low Leute,
gestern 99,35, aber ich glaube mich könnte das Ding noch nicht gut fliegen oder, das
sieht aus als wiegt er die Hälfte von mir, oh das ist schon nice oder, das ist schon
nice, das ist was, das stelle ich mir echt, das stelle ich mir cool vor, sag mal mit was
wird denn das angetrieben, ich sehe da jetzt weder großartige warme Luft hier raus, kann
es ja auch gar nicht, weil da verbrennt das sich ja ein Pobbes, ja das ist gut, das ist
halt irgendeine Turbine, aber, also und hier irgendwelche, irgendwelche Lüfter drin zum
steuern, hier oben, hier drum herum wird wahrscheinlich Treibstoff sein oder, also im Prinzip das
hier ist ein Turbine und drum herum wird wahrscheinlich alles voller Treibstoff sein, mal ganz davon
abgesehen, ich kann mir vorstellen sonderlich lange wird das auch nicht funktionieren, da
kannst du wahrscheinlich eine Viertelstunde oder so mit, noch nicht mal wahrscheinlich
kürzer, aber das ist doch mal was, muss aufpassen dass er nicht gegen den Baum fliegt, also
so schnell ist er auch gar nicht, das ist aber richtig nice, kann man damit unbegrenzt
hoch fliegen, nee, kannst du nicht, mal ganz davon abgesehen da hat er ja auch keine Atemgeschichten
an und sonst was, allein schon da könnte er nicht sonderlich hoch fliegen, ich mein
echt geil ist das schon oder, also das stelle ich mir äußerst pock vor
und jetzt Treibstoff leer, wir müssen mal gucken wie lang es insgesamt gedauert hat,
wir gucken uns mal die Uhrzeit an wenn er landet, wie laut ist das Ding, abfuck brutal
laut wahrscheinlich, ich meine du hast eine Turbine auf dem Rücken, das muss laut sein,
3 Minuten 30 ok, das bezweifle ich, das bezweifle ich dass du da bei einem Sprint einlegst,
das bezweifle ich dass du in 3 Minuten 900 Höhenmeter hoch sprintest, 900 Höhenmeter
sind ja zu Fuß, nee das machst du garantiert nicht, kann er wieder runter fliegen, weiß
ich ob er wieder runter fliegt, da bist du mit dem Heli schneller, ja das bestimmt,
die Sache ist die vielleicht benutzt du das halt, ich bin mir gar nicht sicher ob du
mit dem Heli fliegen könntest bei so einem Wetter, nice jetzt wissen wir Bescheid, also
beim wie schnell man rennen kann merke ich mir immer, der Marathon Weltrekord ist, das
sind irgendwie 42 Kilometer, in mit durchschnittlich 20 kmh glaube ich ist der gelaufen, Moment,
Marathon World Record Pace, 2 Stunden 42, 2 Stunden genau, 2 Stunden für 42 kmh, naja
gut dann weiß er, der muss ja ungefähr, KMH, ja umgerechnet ist das eine Geschwindigkeit
von 20,59 kmh, also der Weltrekord liegt bei pro Kilometer ungefähr 3 Minuten pro Kilometer,
so natürlich die laufen etwas länger als nur den Berg hoch, aber du kannst davon ausgehen
dass der Typ auch so schneller läuft, selbst wenn der danach den Marathon weiter läuft
als wir den normalen Kilometer, also das ist mega krass und das schaffst du im Leben nicht,
ja ich kenne das, es gibt sogar ein Video dazu, es gibt sogar ein Video zu, Moment, 20 kmh,
das heißt ein Laufband, Treadmill oder sowas, oder auf Englisch, Treadmill, ja, da gibt's
sogar ein Video zu, das ist witzig, da fallen die Leute aufs Maul, ne, hier das da, guck
mal, die sind mega am flitzen, Alter und das rennt der Typ einfach mal 42 Kilometer lang,
guckt euch das an, die schaffen das ein paar Sekunden oder der Typ rennt das einfach 42
Kilometer, ok da siehst du halt welche Leute das können, also ich würde, bei mir würde
das ungefähr so aussehen, bei mir würde das ungefähr so aussehen wie bei dem, bei
mir würde das nach 5 Sekunden so aussehen, ja, na der hat's drauf, aber krass oder, also
die haben's mega, also der Typ geht ab, also generell Marathonläufer die gehen mal richtig
ab, so was haben wir dann als nächstes Video, I made my coffee machine wireless mit einem
ESP32, ok lasst mal überlegen, was könnte der Typ machen, der nimmt eine Kaffeemaschine,
muss abends Pulver rein füllen, weil Pulver kriegt er mit einem ESP32 nicht da rein gefüllt,
Pulver rein füllen, im Prinzip braucht er nichts anderes wie ein Relay, was den Stromzufuhr
ein und ausschaltet und da braucht man kein ESP32 rein zu machen mit einem Relay, sondern
irgendeine x-beliebige WLAN Steckdose würde es auch tun, schau mal mal,
wir können doch einfach eine WLAN Steckdose nehmen, ja, wie gesagt einfach eine WLAN Steckdose,
ja gut aber Kaffee und Wasser kannst du abends schon rein machen theoretisch, verkalkt dann
vielleicht ein bisschen, nein ich habe mir den Wasserkocher nicht geholt, ganz ehrlich
ich glaube so eine Kaffeemaschine ist relativ simpel, du hast einen Stromanschluss bzw du
hast einen Schalter und du hast irgendwo einen Stromanschluss und da wird nicht viel sein,
das wird einen Stromanschluss haben, das wird in Schalter gehen und dann zur Heizung, also
viel mehr wird das wahrscheinlich nicht sein, ein Vollautomat Wi-Fi fähig machen, das wäre
cooler und da bin ich mir sicher gibt es bestimmt schon Projekte, ja ok, da sind ESP32 mit einem
Relay dran, easy, easy, das würden wir ja auch hinkriegen.
Ja immer, immer, immer, immer das Neutral Cable rausschmeißen, das ist die beste Idee
aller Zeiten, ja das ist billig, lasst mich raten, das werden jetzt diese blauen Aliexpress
China-Chinesen Relays sein, wartet ab, passt auf blaue China-Chinesen Relays gleich, ja
es ist ein Relay, es gibt ja auch zig verschiedene Typen von Relays.
Massive Unboxing LSMA, sind das die blauen China-Chinesen Relays, zeig her, das sieht
sehr danach aus, ja, ja, ich wusste es, es sind die blauen China-Chinesen Relays, was,
ich wusste es, genau die Dinge, wobei ich ehrlich gar nicht weiß ob das China-Chinesen
Relays sind, das sind die Standarddinger, die es auf jedem billigen Bausatz gibt, aber
von denen habe ich auch einige hier rumfliegen, ich weiß gar nicht ob es China-Relays sind
ehrlich gesagt, das hier ist ja das Relay, der Rest ist ja alles, guck mal, ja, ja, ja,
da ist es hier, Winnie-Pool-Language, das TÜV-Logo ist drauf, das ist bestimmt echt,
das CE-Logo ist bestimmt auch drauf, das ist bestimmt alles komplett legit.
Was sagt die Versicherung, wenn das Ding die Bude abfackelt, dass das davon die Bude
abfackelt ist, sehe ich jetzt nicht wie das passieren sollte, aber wenn es passiert und
man das rausbekommt ist natürlich blöd, aber ich sehe ehrlich gesagt nicht wie das das
auslösen sollte, ich meine, da steckt zwei Kabel da rein und schalte die dann und dann
geht es an und also, dass das abfackelt ist recht unwahrscheinlich, i3, das ist schonmal
der Fall, der weiß Bescheid, i3 und Vim, ich würde zwar im Leben nicht C++ in Vim programmieren,
aber, wobei es ist direkt ESP-Dings gedönst, dann ist es nur C, nicht freiwillig in Vim,
aber immerhin, er hat schonmal den richtigen Window-Manager und den richtigen Editor.
Zeigt er hier sein Wi-Fi-SSD und Passwort, weiß ich nicht, ich sehe es nicht, seht ihr
es?
Ich sehe es nicht, wo?
Das müsste ich auch mal so Chessverfahren, irgendwie sowas in Hintergrund machen, irgendein
Dude der tippt, das muss ja nicht mal ich sein und ein Editor overlayen, das sieht einfach
wie ein Hacker, man, alles.
Ja wenn das abfackelt hast du gelitten, das ist der Grund, ich könnte mir das ohne Autocomplete
gar nicht vorstellen.
Da Benzel, danke für den Sub.
Boah, ich könnte ohne Scheiß, Leute, ich könnte nicht ohne Autocomplete programmieren.
Ich hätte keine Ahnung, ich hätte wirklich keinen Plan, ich könnte mir merken, dass
das wahrscheinlich GPIO Set Level heißt, aber ich könnte mir nicht merken, ob es GPIO Set
Level ist oder Set GPIO Level, weil manche Sachen fangen ja auch gerne mal mit Set und
get, Autocomplete, Beste, fertig.
Wusstet ihr eigentlich, habe ich letztens gesehen in dem Video, jetzt kommt absolut
Pfeiffer Thematik, wusstet ihr eigentlich, dass, also mit dieser Funktion kriegst du heraus,
wie lang der Text ist, also besser gesagt, wie lang bis zum ersten Null Character, wusstet
ihr, dass es mittlerweile auf aktuellen Intel CPUs und ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob
das Intel Only ist oder nicht vielleicht was Übergreifendes, dass es einen Extra Assembly
Befehl gibt oder einen Extra Assembler Befehl gibt, wo du quasi anstelle, also dass du
quasi Strille, also Länge rausfinden, dass du das quasi mehr oder weniger direkt in
einen Assembler Befehl übersetzen kannst, also sprich, es gibt eine interne Instruktion
für die CPU, die quasi mehr oder weniger Strille macht, habe ich letztens in dem Video
gesehen, wusste ich auch nicht, dass die so advanced sind mittlerweile, was da drinnen
ist, ja, das wollte ich jetzt mal sagen, ne, wie heißt der Assembler wirklich, keine Ahnung,
muss mal gucken, vielleicht find ich das Video, gucken wir gleich, ja gut, das ist jetzt
gelassische. An der Stelle, was ganz praktisch wäre, wenn er ein kleines Board genommen hätte,
dann brauchte er die ganzen GPAs aus gar nicht und gerade ESP8266, die auch noch Lock Herעם
gentle typical sehr больш war, die gibt es schon
relativ klein. Lass mich raten, es funktioniert.
Ja, also ganz ehrlich großartig kompliziert ist das jetzt nicht gewesen. Moment, der hat
es noch nicht mal eingebaut. Ja das ist ja mies. Der hätte jetzt noch einen Spannungswandler
hingemusst und dann das ganze in irgendeiner Art und Weise kleinere Bauteile und dass das
da reinpasst. Nach dem Video baut er das wieder ab, ja garantiert. Ja und deswegen
kannst du ohne Probleme in der IoT WLAN Steckdose nehmen. Mal gucken, ich habe das
letzte in dem Video gesehen, nein nein nein. Vielleicht habe ich das Video sogar offen,
ich glaube ich habe nämlich vorhin. Intel Assembly Instructions are wild. Tatsächlich,
doch, das ist das. Was ist das für ein Name?
Rappen ist Skazib. Alles klar.
Also die Zeitangabe da unten erscheint mir ein wenig überzogen für die Zeit was eine
CPU braucht um das auszuführen. Leicht, leicht überzogen. Boom. Nicht schlecht, oder? Also
jetzt müssen wir Rappen ist Skazib, wenn wir mal String Length machen müssen. Aber String
Length machen eh nur die Noobs. Man hat einfach die Länge zusätzlich gespeichert, dann braucht
man das gar nicht. Und kann sich Backslash Null sparen. Könnten Pico Sekunden sein?
Naja. Könnte, könnte. Das war wahrscheinlich gar nichts, außer dass es besser ausschaut.
So, jetzt kommt was jetzt aus der Zeitangabe.
Jetzt gucken wir uns jetzt als nächstes an. Der Internet Boom in Deutschland. DSL macht
es möglich. 2002. Okay, wir können uns angucken, wie wenig sich geändert hat von damals zu
heute. Das Petabyte Project. Was? This? Sind aber ganz schön viele Festplatten. Also das
braucht ja allein schon, also wenn die Dinger anlaufen gleichzeitig zieht das richtig viel
Strom. Also wie viel sind das? 1, 2, 3, 4, 5. Also sind das 15, 15, 20, 40, 60. Okay.
60 Festplatten, wenn das anläuft, braucht das wahrscheinlich 7, 800 Watt kurzzeitig.
Das ist schon dann schlecht. Deswegen ist es das Beste, man lässt es nicht gleichzeitig
anlaufen. Dafür bootet das Ding dann wahrscheinlich 10 Minuten. Welchen Access Point empfiehlst
du? Gar keinen so wirklich. Ich habe ja nicht wirklich viele Access Points getestet. Ich
hatte früher halt ganz normal so ein Billig TP Link Ding. Seit ich hier wohne habe ich
jetzt die UniFi Sachen, die sind jetzt rausgeflogen. Jetzt habe ich diesen einen Ruggus Access
Point. Ansonsten. Nee, anlaufen brauchen die mehr als 5 Watt. Also ich habe jetzt gerechnet
so 10, 15 Watt zum Anlaufen bei der Platte Spitze, also in den Lastspitzen und das sind
60 Stück. Das braucht schon ein bisschen was. Kurzzeitig zum Anlaufen, da später wenn die
Platten da laufen oder gar im Stand-by sind, dann natürlich nicht. Wobei Stand-by ist in
dem Fall auch schwierig. Stell euch mal vor, du hast da ein riesengroßes Rate. Was macht
man da für einen Rate über 60 Platten? Man macht bestimmt keinen Rate 5 und man macht
wahrscheinlich auch keinen Rate 6. Was macht man da, einen Rate 50 oder so oder einen Rate
10, dann 10 ist vielleicht auch nicht gut. Rate 0, würde ich wahrscheinlich. Rate 60,
was auch immer. Zumindest ist es egal. Stell euch mal vor, man macht da einen Rate drüber
und man stellt die Festplatten ein, dass sie nach 10 Minuten in Stand-by gehen, nachdem
keiner draufgeschrieben hat. Das ist ja auch sinnvoll. Braucht ja sonst unsinnig viel
Speicherplatz und auf einmal schreibt jemand über den Samba-Ordner da was drauf. Dann
müssen erstmal die Festplatten anfahren. Das heißt der Typ, der auf dein Samba-Laufwerk
schreibt, der hat erstmal einen Hänger für 5 Minuten, bis alle Festplatten angefahren
sind. Es sei denn du hast da noch ein SSD-Cache davor. Das ist natürlich was anderes. Nennen
danke für den Sub. So, wir gucken uns jetzt an. Der Internet-Boom in Deutschland, DSL
macht es wirklich, von 2002. Na dann, Quelle Deutsche Telekom, das geht schon gut los.
Was, warum kicken die irgendwelche Bälle? Was hat das mit dem Internet zu tun? Das Internet.
Breitband, wisst ihr was damals Breitband war? Das waren 384 mbit, 384kbit oder 768kbit,
das war Breitband. AOL gibt es schon gar nicht mehr.
Alter, ist das Günther Jauch? Der Typ hört sich übelst an wie Günther Jauch.
Der Splitter. Die Angst vor Routern und Splittern. Gab es wirklich Leute, die Monka shaked haben,
als du ihnen gesagt hast, Router und Splitter, die saßen erst ganz ruhig da und dann hast
du gesagt, Router und Splitter und die Leute. Die Angst vor Router und Splitter, Alter,
wie sich das anhört. Ehrlich gesagt, AOL, ich bin mir da gar nicht
so sicher, wie es da aussieht, weil irgendjemand, also das war ja mal bei uns in Deutschland
war das ja irgendwas mit Bertelsmann mal. AOL Wikipedia, gucken wir mal, gucken wir
mal. Hier, die Deutschen International, der Bertelsmann
AG und AOL Europe gegründet, Hamburg, Hansenet, das war das, was später mal Alice wurde und
jetzt Vodafone ist, glaube ich, oder? Ach nee, Telefonica, nicht Vodafone.
O2, ja, ja. Was passiert eigentlich? Ich traue mich da
kaum drauf zu gehen, aber Moment, Moment, Sekunde, Sekunde, AOL.de, kommt man da noch
irgendwo raus? Tatsächlich, ihre Daten, ihr Umfeld ja alles
akzeptieren. Ok, YouTuber, Bibi und Julian haben sich
getrennt. Boah krass, endlich meine Chance. Da habe ich ja nur drauf gewartet. Gut, gut,
krass, dass wir das jetzt erfahren haben. Ok, und die 2015 wurden irgendwie gekauft.
Ok, AOL gibt es nicht mehr. Wie es AOL so verkacken konnte, wusste ich auch nicht.
Ich meine, AOL war mal mit der größten Anbieter, 30 Millionen Zahlen, mit der der größte,
weltweit sogar. Ich hätte jetzt gerne einer der größten. Ja, also, die haben es richtig
verkackt. Ok, weiter, weiter im Text.
Wo sind wir stehen geblieben? Ah, die Angst nehmen vor Routern und Splittern.
Aber es geht vor allem um eines. Zu leise, oder?
Von der Werbung her wird mir immer nur Schnelligkeit vermittelt. In der Werbung ist am gravierendsten
immer, wer ist schneller, ob man irgendwo drin ist oder nicht, oder wie schnell Daten
verarbeitet werden. Das ist das Einzige, was mir eigentlich an Werbung übermittelt wird.
Das Einzige. So, so. Die Teilnehmer haben zwar alle einen
PC zu Hause. Was ist denn das? DSL Modem, oder was soll das sein?
Aber was das neue, schnelle... Leute, das kennt ihr wahrscheinlich gar
nicht mehr. Wisst ihr, was das ist, was die in den Händen hält, was es heute nicht mehr
gibt? Richtig, das ist ein NTBA. Das ist für ISDN-Gedöns.
Du hast ja damals angeschlossen, Splitter in den Splitter DSL Modem in den Splitter
NTBA. Ich glaube, später gab es NTBA und Splitter sogar in einem Gerät.
Aber ISDN braucht ja heute keiner mehr. Beziehungsweise eigentlich, von den Funktionen
her, ist ISDN eine recht coole Geschichte gewesen, aber komplett, ja, außer Mode gekommen.
Was das neue, schnelle Internet wirklich kann, ahnt kaum einer.
In Zeiten, in denen WWW häufig mit weltweites Warten übersetzt...
Was ist ein Splitter? Ein Hub oder so ein Teil? Leitung auf Telefon, ISDN, ne, ein Splitter
ist dafür da, dass das, also, jetzt kommt irgendwo dein Kupferkabel in die Wand, da
ist eine Telefonbuchse und da steckst du in den Splitter sein und der Splitter splittet
die Bandprä, also ne, nicht die Bandprä, die Frequenzen. Ein Splitter splittert die
Frequenzen für DSL und Telefon. Ja.
Was macht ein Splitter? Im Deutschen nennt sich das wahrscheinlich Frequenzweiche oder
irgendwie sowas. Kein Schwimm, das habe ich mir jetzt gerade ausgedacht, ich weiß nicht,
ob es das wirklich gibt. Splitter, Frequenzweiche, gibt es das Wort? Eine Frequenzweiche, okay.
Ne, ich glaube, das war was anderes. Zumindest für Telefonie und Internet.
In Zeiten, in denen WWW häufig mit weltweites Warten übersetzt...
Ja, gut, da hat sich nicht viel geändert.
...sind vorbei. Noch nie war das World Wide Web so schnell wie heute. Fernsehsendungen,
viele Musik und Videos, die Inhalte im...
Leute, das war HD, Hi-Res, Multimedia damals, ja? 41 Kilometer die Sekunde, huge. Und ihr
werdet es nicht glauben, es gibt Leute, die haben damals Porn geguckt in dieser Auflösung,
ja? Kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen heutzutage.
Genießen kann man sie vor allem mit der Digital Subscriber Line, kurz DSL, dem High-Speed-Internet-Anschluss
schlechthin. Das Prinzip, die Leitung wird in einem sogenannten Splitter aufgeteilt...
Oh, jetzt kriegen wir es nochmal erklärt.
...denn das Signal zum Telefonieren und...
Super 3, also das ist ja mal hier, high IQ, render schlechthin.
...für den Datenstrom zum PC. Vorteil, der Benutzer ist während der Computersitzung
immer telefonisch erreichbar. Vorm Splitter gehen die Daten dann zu einem Router und weiter
zum Rechner. Ein Vergleich zeigt die Möglichkeiten, die DSL bietet. Während ein ISDN-Anschluss
links für den Aufbau einer Seite mit einigen Fotos rund 13 Sekunden benötigt hat...
Nee, nee, nee, das muss, Leute, das liegt daran, das hier ist Windows und das hier ist
Mac. Oder ist das überhaupt Mac?
DSL, dieselbe Seite in gerade mal 0,9 Sekunden...
Natürlich legt es nicht an DSL.
Noch deutlicher ist der Unterschied bei sogenannten Videostreams. Oben mit ISDN stoppt der Filmtrailer
bereits nach wenigen Momenten. Über DSL läuft er flüssig und ohne Unterbrechungen
durch.
Doch nicht nur Unterhaltung im Internet wird durch die neuen Geschwindigkeiten noch attraktiver.
Riesenbildschirm, Alter, Riesenbildschirm, 14 Zoll Bildschirm.
Aber Windows XP.
Wir holen natürlich tägliche, aktuelle Informationen über unsere Mannschaft, über unseren Verein
aus dem Internet und wir beschäftigen uns natürlich in erster Linie mit Spielern, mit
eigenen Spielern, aber vor allen Dingen natürlich auch mit Spielern, die auch...
Der hat damals geguckt, ob die Spieler nicht irgendwelche blödsinnigen Sachen von irgendeinem
Interview erzählt haben.
Also das, was unter dem Oberbegriff Scouting läuft und da holen wir die wesentlichen Informationen
aus dem Internet.
Was muss das Internet sein für jemanden wie Sie?
Es muss einfach zu bedienen sein und es muss natürlich sehr, sehr schnell sein und das
alles ist mit dem DSL Anschluss gegeben.
Okay, der Typ ist gesponsert von der Telekom. Müssen wir mal gucken, wer damals mitgesponsert
hat, aber wahrscheinlich die Telekom.
Dani, Lul, danke für den Zap.
Der Nationalspieler hat auch die Scheu vor technischem Zubehör verloren.
Ja, so eine Tastatur kann man schon mal ein bisschen Angst vor haben.
Das ist eigentlich relativ einfach.
Wir brauchen eigentlich nur so eine Starterbox.
Akkuu?
Stimmt, das gab es damals auch noch.
Ist Akkuu nicht heute Vodafone?
Ja, und den Modem Anschluss, also das sind gerade mal drei Kabel, die man stecken muss.
Akkuu war auch Sponsor, ja das passt ja.
Dann müssen wir halt nur noch die eigentliche Verbindung herstellen und das sieht man glaube
ich dann auch ganz gut, dass das sehr, sehr schnell funktioniert, wenn wir hier mal auf
den Button klicken.
Wer hat denn das Ding verwendet zum Einwählen, Alter?
Ah, Internet Explorer 5, so muss das sein.
Er guckt irgendwie ein bisschen leidend bei diesem Interview, oder?
Guckt euch das mal an.
Er guckt irgendwie nicht gerade, sondern nicht glücklich.
Doch nicht immer ist das mit der Technik so einfach, und damit verdient der Mann vor dieser
Tür sein Geld.
Es ist heute auch nicht einfach.
Andreas Baldauf, Sie hatten angerufen bei einem DSL-Anschluss.
Andreas Baldauf rückt dieser Tage häufig zu schwierigen Fällen wie Monika Schulze aus.
Sie ist DSL-Neukundin und hat am Morgen Post mit der Hardware für den Internetanschluss
bekommen.
Nach dem Auspacken die Ernüchterung.
Dann habe ich gesehen, dass sie nicht mal weiß, welches Kabel wo reingehört und wo das hin
geht.
Die meisten Kabel von diesen Dingern passen doch nur in eine Richtung, an eine Stelle rein.
... und auch wenn ich mir den PC angucke, weiß ich auch nicht, wo es da hinten reingesteckt
wird.
Bedienungsanleitung sind hier dabei, sehe ich.
Monika, Alter.
Ja klar.
Und?
Aber ich dachte, wenn ich es sowieso nicht hinkriege, rufe ich lieber jemand an, der...
Ja gut, immer gut, bis sie Geld ausgeben.
Der Mann von CallerPC benötigt für die Installation nur wenige Minuten und zeigt seiner Kundin
sogleich, wie einfach das Anschließen sein kann.
Die Kabel sind idiotensicher gestaltet und passen nur in die...
Oh!
Leute, das hätte Twitter heute schon zur Weißkluft gebracht.
Pass mal auf.
Der Mann von CallerPC benötigt für die Installation nur wenige Minuten und zeigt seiner Kundin
sogleich, wie einfach das Anschließen sein kann.
Jetzt.
Die Kabel sind idiotensicher gestaltet.
Da wäre Twitter hardcore gedriggert heute schon drüber über diese Formulierung.
... und passen nur in die für sie vorgesehenen Buchs.
Nach dem Verstöpfeln folgt das Einrichten der Gesellschaft.
1&1 Profi-Dealer.
Heutzutage würdest du dir unter dem Namen irgendwas Illegales vorstellen, wo du nur
mit dem Tor Browser drauf kommst.
Okay, es ist ja auch nicht der Dealer, sondern der Diler quasi.
Per CD-ROM.
Das Programm fragt nach PIN und Passwort, die im Briefumschlag mitgeliefert werden.
Kurz darauf ist Monika Schulze online.
Boah!
Ein Routine-Eingriff, den sich der Mann vom Service-Dienst natürlich bezahlen lässt.
Na klar, würde ich auch machen.
Lass.
Das...
Da gibt's nix kostenlos.
Das geht bei uns ab 28 Euro pro Stunde los.
Das werden wir auch hier in dem Fall ansetzen, da müssen wir nicht den höheren Tarif wählen.
Das ist jetzt einfach die normale Installation, einmal DSL, und das geht dann weiter zur Netzwerkinstallation,
etc.
Was ist das?
Das kann dann schon mal bis zu 54 Euro pro Stunde gehen, aber das ist eher der Ausnahmefall.
Aber...
Das ist aber billig!
Guck mal, hier, die bezahlt am Ende 30 Euro oder so.
Surfen mit DSL-Antrieb hat seinen Preis.
Über 20 sogenannte Provider bieten den Breitband Zugang ins Netz an.
Wer sich dafür entscheidet, sollte sich...
Ah, die guten...
Die guten...
Ende der 90...
Ich meine, das ist 2002, aber das kann man mal als Ende der 90er durchgehen, die Webseiten
von 2002.
Über 20 sogenannte Provider bieten den Breitband Zugang ins Netz an.
Das war noch zu Zeiten vor HTML5, vor CSS3, vor irgendeinem ordentlichen JavaScript-Standard,
das war noch, wie sagt man so, Wilder Westen quasi, Webentwicklung 2002.
jQuery dürfte damals der heiße Scheiß gewesen sein.
Ich weiß, bin mir gar nicht sicher, wann jQuery rausgekommen ist.
Oh fuck!
Das ist pre-jQuery!
Ach du Scheiße.
Okay, da geht nix.
Nee.
2014, nee, 2005, 2005, okay, Leute, das ist pre-jQuery, da ist, da ist komplett durch,
also...
Wer sich dafür entscheidet, sollte sich zunächst einen Überblick über die Kosten verschaffen.
Neben der obligatorischen Tele...
Gutes 100-Embit-Netzwerk.
Von Grundgebühr sind das die Monat...
Oh, ich bin gar nicht sicher, bin...
Waren das schon 100-Embit, Leute?
Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Mit AJ45-Stecker und so, das war schon 100.
Fällt euch mal auf, dass das genau das gleiche kostet, wie heute, aber heute ist in der
Regel ein bisschen schneller.
Die Lua-Spike, moin, danke für den Zaun.
Caller PC, wie darf man sich das bildlich vorstellen?
Der hat einen Computer unterm Arm, oder?
Ja, kein Wunder, wenn sowas unter dem Tisch hängt mit dem Kabelsalat, da kommst du ja
mit dem Fuß dran und reißt die Hälfte runter.
So, wir sind jetzt hier in unserem 1&1 Rechenzentrum unter der Erde, wie Sie sehen, ist nicht
so einfach hier reinzukommen und überall sind Kameras, wo man sie beobachtet jetzt
die ganze Zeit.
Und was Sie hier sehen, diese blauen Türen, das ist der Vorgänger von Marcel Davis, quasi.
Ich zeige Ihnen jetzt mal einen Raum.
Vollgestopft mit...
Marcel Davis 1.0, Beta.
...modernster Elektronik.
Den hohen Preis für DSL-Anschlüsse erklärt Vorstandssprecher Andreas Gauger mit diversen
Zusatzleistungen, die der Kunde bekommt, ob er sie will oder nicht.
Bei 1&1 bieten wir einige sehr spannende Extra-Services, dafür haben wir auch hier dieses tolle Rechenzentrum
gebaut.
Wir machen Ihnen einen Virenschutz für Ihre E-Mail, Sie bekommen Möglichkeiten, einen
Anrufbeantworter im Internet zu haben, eine eigene Homepage, eine eigene Domain ist für
uns als inklusive und das betreiben wir hier aus diesem Rechenzentrum heraus.
Der Anwender kann in Deutschland aus mehr als 140 verschiedenen DSL-Tarifen auswählen,
ein wahrer Dschungel.
Ich habe nie verwendet diese komischen Desktop-Clients, die Telekom hatte auch so ein Ding, da konnte
es hier dann so ein extra Telekom, weiß gar nicht, wie sich das nannte, so eine Telekom-Software-Sammlung
installieren und das war dann so eine Mischung aus Messenger, E-Mail-Programm, Browser, teilweise
noch BTX gab es früher bei der Telekom noch, falls irgendjemand BTX kennt, das war noch
Pre-WWW-Gramm, Bildschirmtext, BTX, sah ein bisschen aus wie Videotext, BTX.
Da gibt es für jeden Benutzetyp das passende, ein Einsteiger oder Normal-User benutzt DSL,
um seine E-Mails regelmäßig zu checken und auch mal bei Ebay ein Schnäppchen zu ergattern.
Also ich habe zu dieser Zeit angefangen, 2002 24-7-MMO-Kreisel-Grind zu machen, dann war
ich zu der Zeit definitiv kein normaler Benutzer.
Für so jemanden empfiehlt sich ein Zeit-Tarif, minutegenaue Abrechnung der Benutzerzeit garantiert
eine gute Kostenkontrolle, günstige Angebote haben Microsoft sowie Freenet oder Tiskali.
Trotzdem heißt das nicht, so Arthur Kessin vom DSL-Team, dass für Normal-User nicht
auch ein ISDN-Anschluss ausreichend sein kann.
Also zunächst einmal muss jeder Kunde für sich entscheiden, wie viel Zeit er ungefähr
im Internet verbringt, denn wenn man unter 20 Stunden pro Monat unterwegs ist, lohnt
sich die Anschaffung des DSL-Anschlusses eher weniger.
Was ist das für eine bescheuerte Aussage?
So, wenn ich 20 Stunden im Internet bin und möchte irgendwelche Filme gucken oder irgendwelche
bisschen höher aufgelöste Sachen machen, das geht mit ISDN schlicht und ergreifend
nicht.
Nur weil ich unter 20 Stunden drinne bin, heißt das doch nicht, dass ich viele Sachen
gar nicht benutzen will und gerade die Ultra Casuals wollen doch bestimmt mal irgendwie
einen neuen Filmtrailer gucken, sogar 2002, das ist ja blödsinn, es war damals schon
blödsinnig.
Eine zweite Gruppe umfasst User, die sich im Netz gelegentlich Musik anhören, Videos
anschauen oder Länge...
Musik anhören kannst du dir mit ISDN auch nicht gescheit, ordentliche Bandbreite für
Musik fängt ab 128...
MP3, MP3 fängt ab 128 Kilobit an und das ist schon...
Also heute wird sich keiner mit 128 Kilobit MP3 anhören, aber ich sag mal, hörbar ordentlich
ist es ab 128 Kilobit und das kannst du mit ISDN nicht anhören, es sei denn mit Kanalbindung
und sehr gut und sehr viel Glück.
Also allein schon dafür hast du damals, wenn du ordentlich Musik hörst, hast du DSL gebraucht.
Für solche Nutzer empfiehlt sich ein sogenannter Volumentarif, eine zeitliche Beschränkung
gibt es nicht, jedoch darf nur eine bestimmte Menge an Daten mit dem World Wide Web ausgetauscht
werden und das zum Festpräsent...
1-5 Gigabyte, da machen die Boomer heute Facebook 5 mal auf und dann hast du das schon, na gut
übertrieben, aber geht in die Richtung.
1 Gigabyte reicht aber für bis zu 30.000 Internetseiten, empfehlenswert sind hier Freenet...
Was ein Vergleich man!
Lycos, da sind die mit dem Hund, die gibt es auch nicht mehr.
Die Möglichkeiten von DSL voll ausreizen kann aber nur ein Power-User.
Moment, Moment!
Kriegen wir da einfach Filesharing gezeigt gerade?
Kriegen wir da gerade Filesharing in einem Beitrag gezeigt?
Sehe ich das richtig, ja?
Power-User, er lädt große Datenmengen als Video oder Musikdateien auf seinen Reifen.
Jaja, alles garantiert, ganz bestimmt, legit erworben, ja?
Oder Musikdateien auf seinen Rechner, solch ein Vielnutzer braucht eine Flatrate, das heißt
berufs-Uniur online zum Fixpreis, eine zeitliche Beschränkung gibt es nicht und die Menge
der transferierten Daten spielt auch keine Rolle, günstige Flatrates haben...
Dafür hatte ich damals eins und eins, ich hab damals auch so einen Brief bekommen, damals
hatte ich, wenn du die Flatrate viel benutzt hast, hatte ich eins und eins angeschrieben
und hat gefragt, ob du nicht zu einem anderen Anbieter wechseln musst und hat dir glaub
ich sogar noch 100 Euro gegeben, wenn du wechselst und in dieser Mail, äh nicht in dieser Mail,
in diesem Brief stand sinngemäß sowas drin, seien wir doch mal ehrlich, das lohnt sich
nicht.
Da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern.
Warte mal, eins und eins, Flatrate-Brief, mal gucken, ob es davon noch irgendwelche...
Flatrate-Brief, äh ja, da was suche ich denn als da, ist ja keine Kündigung gewesen,
es ist, es ist auch nicht 2002 unbedingt gewesen, das ist schon...
Anschreiben?
Was zum?
Das traue ich mich nicht aufzumachen.
Ähm, aber, das haben die damals verschickt, ja?
Ich muss mir das mal auf dem zweiten Monitor angucken, ob man diese Seite gefahrlos öffnen
kann.
Ah, anscheinend, anscheinend kann man dies gefahrlos öffnen.
Erhielt ich einen Brief?
Okay, genau, sowas, sowas in der Richtung haben die damals verschickt.
Im Rahmen einer Kostensparung, ich verspreche hier als Kundenbereiter, hat sie gezielt,
um ihnen Möglichkeiten zur Kosteneinsparung aufzuzeigen, dabei habe ich, wette, nee, das
war was anderes.
Das ist unsere Nutzung, damit die Betriebskosten stark strapazieren, dass sie uns nicht rechnen.
Ja, genau, ähm, anders führt es dazu, dass...
Wenn sie kündigen, bekommst du 100 Euro Prämie, genau.
Antwort-Fax musstest du noch unterschreiben.
Ja, sowas habe ich damals auch bekommen.
Und damals hast du das bekommen, ab, oder wie viel hat er verbraucht?
92 Gigabyte!
Das war damals, 2005, unglaublich massiv, mega viel, ja.
Heute guckst du dir ein paar Filme an, da ist es schon durch.
Könnte man nicht kündigen und erneubestellen, ich weiß nicht, ob man die gebaten konnte.
Ich habe damals nicht gekündigt.
Ich bin bei denen geblieben und habe mir gedacht, das ist nicht mein Problem.
Ja.
Flat ist flat, so dachte ich mir das auch.
So, was gucken wir uns jetzt an hier, was haben wir, der Internet-Boom in Deutsch geht,
das haben wir uns gerade angeschaut.
Sieben Essential Command Line Tools, nope, nope, Windows, achja, die CT hat ein Video,
der hat ein Video dazu gemacht, ob Windows 11 sechs Monate nach Release jetzt besser
ist.
Und ich habe ja dazu auch letztens ein Video gemacht und aus meiner Sicht, naja, ne, und
mal gucken, was die CT dazu sagt.
Und die völlig kaputten Widgets, bleib dran.
Liebe, in diesem Video werfen wir mal einen Blick auf Windows 11, ein halbes Jahr nach
der Veröffentlichung und schauen, welche der anfänglichen Probleme von Microsoft inzwischen
behoben worden sind.
Okay, lass mich raten, lass mich raten, keins, oder eins vielleicht, aber ich persönlich
tippe ja auf keins.
Beispiel den Gruppierungszwang in der Taskbar.
Oh ja, das habe ich ja auch immer im Video dazu genüge, das ist so hängen geblieben.
Wer bei Microsoft hat sich das angeguckt und hat gedacht, das ist eine gute Idee.
Kennst du Neues der Anwenderkurs?
Was?
Neues der Anwenderkurs?
Ne.
Hä?
Was sagt mir nichts?
Soll das sein?
Die Teams-Verwirrung und die völlig kaputten Widgets, bleib dran.
Liebe Hackerinnen, liebe Internet-Surfer, herzlich willkommen hier bei... Ja ist da gut, regt
euch ab.
Dieses Video wird gesponsert von Only Off, sondern ist auch komplett Open Source.
Erbung, Ende.
Vor etwas mehr als einem halben Jahr ist Windows 11 offiziell veröffentlicht worden.
Ja und ich sag mal, es war nicht das Produkt, das die Welt mit Jubelstürmen gefeiert hat.
Die Leute sind nicht...
Von was ist dieses Originalvideo eigentlich?
Das habe ich schon öfters gesehen für irgendwelche Dinge.
Von was ist das Originalvideo eigentlich?
... nicht sonderlich heiß drauf gewesen und zwar auch heute noch nicht.
Schaut man sich die Zahlen von Ed Duplex von April 2022 an, die 5000 Microsoft Store Apps
ausgewertet haben, die auf Rechnern mit Windows 10...
Hey, die Statistik kommt mir bekannt vor.
Moment, welches Video war zuerst, mein Video oder das CT-Video?
Mein Video war zuerst, nice.
Aber da vorab gesehen, die haben natürlich alle das Gleiche gesehen.
... 11 laufen, ja dann kommt Windows 11 nur auf einen Anteil von läppischem 20%, der
Rest ist immer noch Windows 10.
Ja und das hat keine finanziellen Gründe, denn das Update auf Windows 11 ist kostenlos.
Auch wenn Microsoft immer mal wieder damit gedroht hat, man müsse bis zu einem bestimmten
Zeitpunkt updaten, danach wird es kostenpflichtig, hat Microsoft das nie durchgezogen.
Auch bei Windows 10 schon nicht.
Heute lässt sich auch eine 13 Jahre alte Windows 7 Lizenz gratis auf Windows 11 upgraden.
Ja, aber viele Leute machen es trotzdem nicht.
Wir haben uns jetzt mal angeschaut, ob das...
Die Leute hätten auch nicht auf Windows 10 abgecradet, wenn sie nicht gemusst hätten.
... der ersten Monate irgendwas gebracht hat, das heißt, dass Microsoft die konstruktive
Kritik angenommen hat und Dinge behoben hat.
Auf vier Sachen haben wir uns konzentriert.
Nummer eins, Taskleisten, Gruppierungen...
Oh ja, nein, das ist immer noch so, das ist immer noch so.
... Stellvertretend für die restliche Welt steht, dann ist das hier definitiv mit Abstand
das größte Problem.
Nämlich ruft man ein Programm mehrfach auf, also...
Warum?
Warum Microsoft?
... gleichzeitig offen hat, dann gruppiert Windows die Icons in der Taskleiste automatisch
zusammen.
Das heißt, dass nur noch ein Icon zu sehen ist...
So was hängengebliebenes.
... und die Icons in der Bestandte sieht man erst, wenn man mit der Maus drauf geht.
Das ist zumindest auch schon in Windows 10 so.
Aber...
So hängengeblieben.
... in Windows 10 lässt sich diese Funktion ganz einfach abstellen, einfach rechtsklick
auf Taskleiste...
Es ist ja okay, wenn es jemand gefällt, aber man sollte zumindest die Option bieten,
es abzuschalten.
... dann Taskleiste-Einstellungen, dann Schaltflächen der Taskleiste, gruppieren und dann auf nie.
Bei CT haben das sehr viele Leute so eingestellt.
Ja, ich auch.
Denn arbeitet man mit mehreren Dokumenten, leidet die Übersicht sonst enorm, wenn man
nicht weiß, welches Dokument welches ist.
Man kann das einfach nicht richtig sehen, auch mit der Vorschau nicht.
Hier z.B.
bei Teams.
Welches Fenster ist jetzt noch mal welches?
Und ganz allgemein, das Umschalten dauert in der Praxis länger als bei nicht gruppierten
Icons.
In Windows 11 lässt sich das Problem mit Bordmitteln nicht beheben, es gibt nicht mal
irgendwelche Registry Hacks.
Will man das Verhalten ändern, braucht man zusätzliche Software, z.B.
Start 11 oder Start All Back.
Beide kosten Geld, Start 11 mindestens 7,99 Euro, Start All Back...
Ja, also ganz ehrlich, beides ist wahrscheinlich keine Source Software auf GitHub, die würde
ich mir nicht installieren.
Keine Ahnung, was ich mir auf meinen Rechner hole, wenn ich den Crap installiere.
Start All Back 4,99 Dollar.
Kostlos ist der Explorer Patcher auf GitHub.
Ich habe das mal ausprobiert, war gut.
Aber all dieses Software greift tief in eure Windows Installation ein.
Sobald Microsoft was patcht, könnte das fiese Probleme geben.
Nur, dass ihr gewarnt seid, dass einmal pro Jahr...
Das erinnert mich an eine Sache, die ich früher mal gemacht habe und mich super krass Hacker-Man
gefühlt habe.
Aber ich habe mal unter Windows 98 SE die Windows 95 Explorer reingepatcht, weil in
irgendeiner komischen Zeitrift stand damals als Tipp, dass Windows 98 damit viel viel
schneller ist.
Was auch stimmt, nur die Hälfte funktioniert danach nicht mehr.
Ich konnte z.B. danach meine Grafikkarten-Settings nicht mehr aufmachen, weil es das Panel einfach
nicht gegeben hat unter Windows 95 im Explorer.
Aber es ja der Windows 98 3 war, richtig hängen geblieben, ich weiß nicht warum ich so Dinge
gemacht habe.
Aber tja, so sieht es aus.
Planete Funktionsupdate 22 H2 soll im Spätsommer für Windows 11 kommen und bislang sieht es
nicht so aus.
Warum heißt es eigentlich nicht H2 22?
Das würde sich dann zweites halb... So heißt es ja 2022, halb Jahr 2, ich fände zweites
halb Jahr 2022 so aus, deutsche Aussprechweise sinnvoller, also 2H22.
Sortiert sich einfacher, das ist ein guter Punkt, da hast du recht, dann sollte man es
wahrscheinlich so lassen.
Als würde die Option... Nein, 2H22, 2H22, aber mit dem Sortieren ist schon gut, da habt
ihr recht.
Das erste, was ich gemacht habe unter diesen paar VMs, wo wir Windows 11 ausprobiert haben,
ist dieses Ding ausblenden, das ausblenden, also was ich immer ausblende, ich blende das
aus, ich blende das aus, ich blende eigentlich so ziemlich alles aus, was es da unten standardmäßig
gibt.
Standardmäßig ein Chat-Icon auf der Taskleiste, hinter dem sich Teams verbirgt.
Wer aber jetzt denkt, ah cool, Teams nutze ich eh, da brauche ich das nicht installieren.
Nein, Pustekuchen, das Vorinstallierte ist sehr wahrscheinlich nicht das Teams, das ihr
beruflich benutzt.
Hä?
Was?
Man kann sich da nämlich nur mit privaten Accounts anmelden.
Ja und... Was?
Ernsthaft?
Ich meine, ich habe es nie ausprobiert, aber warum?
Was ist denn der Sinn davon, Teams zu integrieren in Windows und dann ist es nicht mal das vollständige
Teams?
Alter Microsoft, Mensch, warum macht ihr so einen Shit?
Warum?
Warum macht ihr das so unglaublich ätzend?
Warum wollt ihr, dass man abgefuckt ist, wenn man euren Kram verwendet?
Warum?
Ich verstehe es nicht.
Ja und Microsoft hat seit Neuesten noch mehr Verwirrung in Petto, wenn man nämlich den
Client herunterladen will, gibt es den einmal für Zuhause.
Moment, Microsoft Teams auf den Windows Desktop herunterladen, Teams für Zuhause oder Kleinunternehmen,
Teams für Berufe, Schule und Studium.
Ok, so wie ich Microsoft kenne, wird bei beiden exakt das gleiche heruntergeladen, aber wenn
wir jetzt mal von ausgehen würden, dass das zwei unterschiedliche Sachen sind, ich hätte
keine Ahnung, was ich runterladen soll, soll ich jetzt... Was ist denn das für ein widersprüchlichste
Wort?
What the fuck?
Was?
Das ergibt ja überhaupt... Das hat gar keinen Sinn.
Ich wüsste gar nicht, was ich runterladen soll, ehrlich gesagt.
Beruf, Schule, Studium.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Zuhause oder Kleine Unternehmen und für Beruf, Schule und Studium.
Das ist ja richtig hängen geblieben.
Beruf und kleine Unternehmen, also Teams für die Freizeit und Schule und Teams für die
Arbeit.
Aber für Microsoft war das offenbar zu logisch und hat das deshalb komplett verkehrt... Oder
die Website ist einfach nur grottenschlecht in Deutsch übersetzt, das kommt ja bei Microsoft
auch öfters mal vor.
... angesetzt, sodass zumindest ich nicht mehr weiß, welche Version welche ist.
Arbeite ich bei einem kleinen Unternehmen?
Zumindest laut EU-Definition sind kleine Unternehmen, welche die maximal 10 Millionen Euro Umsatz
erwirtschaften.
Muss ich also jetzt wissen, wie viel Umsatz mein Arbeitgeber macht, um die richtige Teams-Version
auszuwählen?
Oder wie verhält sich das?
Also wirklich jetzt mal, bei einer vorinstallierten Software, bei dem populärsten Desktop-Betriebssystem
der Welt, da sollte man noch vorher vielleicht mal etwas genauer hingucken, ob das alles
logisch ist für die Kundschaft.
Eigentlich ist das nämlich relativ einfach zu erklären.
Es gibt nämlich einmal das sogenannte Microsoft-Konto und einmal das sogenannte Geschäftskonto.
Das erste kann man sich als Privatmensch selbst anlegen, früher hieß das Windows-Live-ID,
und nur das lässt sich mit der vorinstallierten Teams-Version nutzen.
Das Geschäftskonto dagegen ist ein Konto, das von einer Administratorin oder einem Administrator
erstellt wurde, zum Beispiel auch...
Warum, jetzt mal eine blöde Frage, warum gibt es überhaupt zwei verschiedene Teams-Versionen?
Warum kann es nicht nicht einfach installieren und anhand dessen, mit was ich mich einlogge,
dann die jeweiligen Funktionen anzeigen oder nicht anzeigen?
Das macht jeder so.
Warum kann das nicht Microsoft so machen?
Ein Arbeitgeber eurer Schule oder eurer Uni und das funktioniert dann mit der anderen
Teams-Version.
Was ein Scheiß, was ein Bullshit.
Die Bewertung von Microsoft hat hier rein gar nichts verbessert bei der Teams-Verwörung.
Jetzt ehrlich, Teams ist definitiv nicht meine Lieblings-Version.
So schlecht.
Es gibt zwei Widgets.
Ja, apropos, wenn man was macht, vielleicht kurz vorher drüber nachdenken.
Okay, Chat, Frage, wer Windows 11 hat, wer verwendet diese Widgets?
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob es nicht schon unter Windows 11 irgendwelche Widgets gab.
Ich habe keine Widgets verwendet, äh, Windows 10, äh, ich habe auch unter Windows 7 und
unter Windows XP und was, ich habe nie Widgets verwendet, unter Windows, noch nie, weil ich
im Prinzip mir eh sicher bin, Microsoft krempelt das laufend um und die Widgets zacken, also.
Die sogenannten Widgets sind standardmäßig bei Windows 11 aktiviert, ja, und es ist einfach
so, die Widgets sind nach wie vor ein kompletter Verkehrsunfall.
Ja, Verkehrsunfall, das passt gut, denn hier sollen jetzt eigentlich Verkehrsmittel sein.
Na geil.
Das funktioniert ja wirklich erstklassig.
Super, toll.
Also sollten, stattdessen gibt es dieses geile Icon mit so einem zerrissenen Bild oder was
das darstellen soll, das habe ich jedenfalls zum letzten Mal im Internet vor ca. 150 Jahren
gesehen, wenn da irgendwelche Bilder nicht richtig laden wollten.
Und ich betone nochmal, das ist hier jetzt nicht irgendwelche Beta-Software, sondern das
ist das ganz normale Windows-
Moment was, Chat, das funktioniert?
Moment, ich verwende Windows 11 mit den Vista Sidebar Gadgets, das funktioniert?
Kann man, kann man unter Windows 10 auch die Vista Sidebar Gadgets verwenden?
Widget, Gadget, oder auch nicht.
Warum ist das so schlecht?
Ich meine ganz im Ernst, selbst wenn das was angezeigt hätte, was will ich damit?
Ich könnte euch noch dran erinnern, wie sie in diesem Windows-Resentations-Ding die ganze
Zeit erzählt haben, so beautiful und das war so richtig Apple-Style nur in schlecht.
Das Apple-Zeug, das liefert ja meistens wenigstens halbwegs das was die ganzen Apple-Verfechter
am Endeffekt haben wollen, aber hier, der Typ hat auch halb geweint, erinnert ihr euch
noch dran?
Der Typ hat halb geheult, der hat halb geweint in dem Livestream, guckt euch an, der weint
gleich, so emotional ist Windows 11, das ist ja zu kurz vor dem Heulen, Alter, Zettel, guckt
euch das an, das ist doch, wollt ihr mich verarschen, der weint gleich, der weint
gleich, den wir liebenến解ten wir archives und strategies?
Was der wurde gekündigt?
Ist das chebait?
Wurde der wirklich rausgesmist?
än würde ich?
Nee der ist immer noch da, der ist immer noch da.
Wie heißt er?
Pa Pa Pa?
PaSOS?
Oder irgendwie so?
Wie heißt dieser Dude?
Windows 11 Presentation-Dude.
Dude. Ich weiß nicht, wie der heißt, Alter. Wie hieß der? Irgendwie Pa...Pasos oder...ah ne, wie hieß der...geil. Wie heisst denn der Typ?
Moin, der steht doch am Anfang bestimmt. Der steht doch am Anfang.
Der steht doch bestimmt am Anfang. Jetzt, jetzt.
Okay, wie heisst der? Panos. Panos. Panos. Microsoft.
Nein, der ist immer noch da. Der ist immer noch da.
Der ist immer noch da. Alles klar.
Aber der...ich finde das so krass, wie der halber Wein ist da. Das ist Wahnsinn. Also...
Mann. Wo sind wir einstehen geblieben?
Ja.
Nach dem ersten Widget-Start und mehrmaligem Aus- und Einklappen. So, und dann noch Microsoft.
Wieso soll ich in Osterode am Harz wohnen? Das ist von meinem echten Standort mehr als 100 Kilometer entfernt.
Und meine Adresse habt ihr auch, weil ich sie im Microsoft-Account angegeben habe.
Ja, Microsoft weiß selber nicht, bei wie viel ihrer gesammelten Sachen wo was liegt.
Und den könnt ihr ja auch mal auslesen, weil ja die Outlook-Termine da auch...
Also Windows wirkt so amateurhaft an vielen Stellen. Ich will nicht sagen, dass es unter Linux besser ist, ja.
Unter Linux hast du andere. Unter Linux hast du auch einige Probleme, aber du hast andere Probleme, ja.
Es ist nicht alles rosig, ja. Und unter Mac definitiv auch nicht. Aber was Microsoft unter Windows macht wirkt so amateurhaft.
Wir docktern irgendwo rum, wissen selber nicht so genau, was wir machen. Es ist wie wir.
...werden können.
Hä?
Ja, und natürlich die News in den Widgets. Das ist zu großen Teilen der reinste Klatschpresse Clickbait.
Dieter Bohlen, die ganze Wahrheit über sein DSDS-Comeback, ja. Da wollte ich schon immer mal wissen.
Und man kann zwar auf keine News mehr von XY anzeigen.
Wundervibe. Okay, wird da was gelernt? Es gibt eine Webseite, die so heißt.
Nur wird das halt sehr oft ignoriert, sodass man den Kram immer noch sehen muss. Egal wie oft man das anklickt.
Abhilfe, Rechtsklick auf die Taskleiste, Widgets hier auf Aus. Und weg ist der Kram komplett.
Chat auch aus. Chat auch gleich ausschalten.
Es geht übrigens genauso mit diesem komischen Chat aka Teams für Zuhause oder kleine Unternehmen.
Kann man auch einfach mit Clickback machen.
Bewertung, es hat sich nichts geändert mit den schrottigen Widgets.
Nummer 4, Kontoszwang. Ich hatte ja anfangs schon gesagt, ein Windows 11 Update klappt mit ewig alten Windows Lizenzen.
Microsoft scheint also mit Privatleuten die Windows-Lizenz-Verhältnis kein Geld verdienen zu wollen.
Sondern das Geld kommt von PC Herstellern und Unternehmen.
Mit dem nächsten Update ist angeblich unter Windows Professional auch so ohne Weiteres nicht mehr möglich, einen Offline-Account zu verwenden.
Ich kriege echt Aggression, wenn ich mir dieses gegängle und amateurhafte Rumgefrickel von Microsoft angucke.
Ich kriege da richtig Ausschlag bei, weil es mich abfuckt, wenn ich mehr Aufwand habe durch Sachen, die nicht sein müssten.
Ich kriege immer wieder Anfälle, wenn Sachen an irgendwelchen Stellen angepasst werden, weil sich irgendeiner gedacht hat,
ah ja, das muss jetzt sein und ich mich dann wieder komplett mir was überlegen muss, wie kriege ich es jetzt wieder gescheit integriert. Das ist so abartig, Alter.
Lieber Geld mit seinen Office-Abos und seinem App-Store, genannt Microsoft-Store, verdienen.
Ja, den haben sie jetzt ja unbenannt und da ist jetzt natürlich viel besser der App-Store.
Natürlich möglichst alle dazu gezwungen werden, einen Microsoft-Account zu verwenden. Ohne Account keine Software-Verkäufe oder Abos.
Ja, und während in den Anfangszeiten von Windows 11 nur bei der Installation von Windows 11 Home so lange gemeckert wurde, bis man einen Account angegeben oder angelegt hat,
wird es künftig auch bei der Pro-Version so sein. Bislang konnte man da ganz offiziell Offline-Konten anlegen.
Als Trick klappt bislang noch, mehrfach eine falsche E-Mail-Adresse anzugeben, aber die Frage ist, wie lange noch?
Bewertung der Account-Zwang wird künftig eher noch schlimmer als besser.
Mein Fazit, von den häufig kritisierten Windows-Problem-Bereichen, also die Sachen, die ihr hier so kommentiert oder die sonst die CT-Redaktion so erreichen,
hat Microsoft einfach im ersten halben Jahr gar nichts verbessert.
Dachte ich mir, habe ich richtig gelegen am Anfang, oder? Dass nichts gefixt wurde.
Ganz schön schade. Stattdessen gibt es im für den spätsommer geplanten ersten Feature-Update, auch bekannt als 22H2,
irgendwelche ganz anderen Detail-Verbesserungen, nach denen niemand gefragt hat. Gibt es da überhaupt Verbesserungen? Eine kleinere Task-Leiste für Tablets.
Boah, da habe ich drauf gewartet. Endlich. Microsoft, aber huge Verbesserungen. Das haben wir gebraucht. Alter, Poggers.
Oder, dass die Boot-Animation wieder geändert wurde. Das sieht doch so aus. Statt dem hier gibt es jetzt das hier.
Geil, Microsoft. Da hat die Welt. Warum? Das ist das, was ich meine. Warum? Warum doktern die an so einem Shit rum, Mann?
Ich meine, das wäre nicht schlimm. Ohne Scheiß. Ich habe damit überhaupt kein Problem. Das können die machen, wenn das Bestandteil ist von irgendeinem sinnvollen Update.
Ich habe überhaupt keine Probleme damit, wenn die die Boot-Animation verschönern oder was auch immer. Aber du kannst doch nicht sagen, okay, es ist immer noch scheiße.
Wir kacken auf unsere User. Wir geben einen Scheiß drauf komplett, was man ja sieht am Online-Account-Zwang. Und dann, ja, im nächsten Update gibt es zwar nichts von dem, was ihr haben wollt,
aber es gibt jetzt einen Kreis anstatt Punkte bei einer Boot-Animation. Ja, geil. Und das ist auch alles ganz nett, aber besser wäre es doch,
erst mal die von der Kundschaft geforderten Sachen zu finden. Obwohl ich hier natürlich den Finger in die Wunde lege, favorisiere ich Windows 11 dennoch.
Wir werden alle früher oder später Windows 11 brauchen, weil Microsoft wird sicherlich dafür sorgen, dass neue Sachen, wie gesagt, mit Direct Storage und so fängt es jetzt an.
Nicht mehr gescheit unter Windows 10, wenn sie überhaupt existieren, wird es das nicht mal gescheit geben.
Also in spätestens im Jahr oder so müssen wir wahrscheinlich alle umsteigen.
Windows 10 und benutze das privat auch noch als Hauptbetriebssystem, vor allem weil es einfach deutlich moderner aussieht als Windows 10 und sich schwupsiger anfühlt.
Vor allem ist Windows 10 keine langfristige Alternative, denn es wird nur bis Oktober 2025 Updates geben.
Aber wie schon gesagt, Microsoft sollte vielleicht in Zukunft besser auf die Kundschaft hören, denn der Windows-Marktanteil sinkt seit Jahren stetig.
Und mit Linux, Mac OS...
Leute, nächstes Jahr, wenn ich das so sehe, wisst ihr was nächstes Jahr ist?
Ihr wisst genau, 2023, was wird das sein?
Das Jahr des...
Ihr wisst...
Das Jahr des Linux-Desktops, genau, so wie die letzten 30 Jahre auch.
Ok, 20, 20 Jahre.
Aber vielleicht schaffen wir die 1% immerhin, ne?
Seit Jahren stetig und mit Linux, Mac OS und Chrome OS gibt es starke Alternativen.
Tschüss.
Alter, ich muss jetzt das Thema wechseln, weil bei diesem Thema rege ich mich immer viel zu sehr auf.
Ja, Gigachat Linux User.
Und du hast es richtig gemacht, weil ansonsten hättest du nicht genug Linux geschrieben,
wüsste ja genau, was dann passiert wäre, wenn du einfach nur Linux geschrieben hättest.
Korrekt.
Das wäre dann passiert.
Windows 11 Event Supercut.
Skyrim, das hat mich ja damals auch, da mussten wir auch ordentlich kecken,
als die ernsthaft Skyrim gezeigt haben in Windows 10, äh, Windows 11.
Skyrim, hättet ihr nix irgendwie noch was anderes modernes zeigen können?
Games.
Naja.
Oh Mann.
Okay, das schauen wir uns jetzt an.
Komm, wir können noch was.
Warte, ich bin schon an 2 Stunden 46.
Ohne ich hab Hunger.
Was gucken wir?
Eine Sache können wir uns mal angucken.
Wir können uns mal wieder so, lohnt sich das angucken?
Die finde ich immer gut gemacht.
Lohnt sich das?
Also was lohnt sich denn heute?
Sanitär, Heizungs- und Klimatechnik.
Was, warum der Metaverse-Hype dumm ist?
Äh, weil, weil der Zuck das erzählt hat.
Und wenn der Zuck was erzählt, dann ist das in der Regel, äh, mit Vorsicht zu genießen.
Weißt du, warum Willi Pete Cass, ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ich hab auch schon ewig nix mal von ihm gehört.
Absolut keine Ahnung, warum der aufgehört hat.
Debian oder Arch, by the way?
Also, komm, jetzt.
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Nix Debian.
Arch.
Wobei, ich muss sagen, ähm, jetzt mal Arch, by the way-Meme außen vor.
Ich verwende aktuell noch Manjaro.
Da sagen ja die richtigen Arch-Kenner, dass das ja auch kein richtiges Arch Linux ist.
Und auf, äh, den meisten Systemen, wo ich es mir aussuchen kann, Server-technisch,
läuft Ubuntu-Server drauf, außer auf den Raspberry Pi's.
Da läuft natürlich, äh, Raspbian heißt ja nicht mehr, Raspberry Pi OS drauf, was ein Debian ist.
Also eigentlich ist meine Mischung aus Linux daheim
Manjaro auf dem Desktop, Debian auf den Raspberry Pi's und Ubuntu auf allen anderen Dingern
und auch auf den Cloud-VM's.
Also, ist mein Stack quasi, können wir da irgendwas Gescheites haben?
Ub, Ubd?
Ubdema?
Der Ubdema-Stack?
Also ich verwende den Ubdema-Stack daheim.
Mittlerweile, du musst das alles in so coole Abkürzungen abmachen heutzutage und Stack dahinter schreiben.
So, also, was meint ihr eben?
Warum Metaverse-Hype dumm ist und es niemals kommen wird?
Ja, dann erzähl mal.
Der macht ja teilweise nice Videos.
Wir haben ja schon ein paar von ihm geguckt, waren durchaus coole Sachen dabei.
Guck mal, ist denn Ubuntu selber auf dem Raspberry Pi brauchbar?
Ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob ich Ubuntu schon einmal auf dem Raspberry Pi...
Doch, hab ich! Ja, geht.
Aber es gab ein paar Sachen, die mich genervt haben, warum ich wieder Raspbian drauf gemacht hab.
Ich bin mir auch gar nicht mehr sicher, was der Grund war, warum ich Ubuntu drauf gemacht hatte.
Es hat wahrscheinlich irgendeinen Grund gehabt.
Ich weiß es aber nicht mehr.
Aber du hast mit Raspbian mehr oder weniger alles, was du brauchst.
So, zeig mal her.
Hast du dir das mit dem iPad Pro und Raspberry Pi von TechCraft schon angebracht?
Nee, schick mal einen Link.
Der Hype um das Metaverse ist lächerlich dumm.
Aber fangen wir mal vorne an.
Erst Anfang des Jahres hat MontanaBlack Werbung gemacht für einen Hitchler-Gut.
Na gut, MontanaBlack macht auch Werbung für komische Glücksspielseiten.
Da würde ich jetzt nicht so viel drauf geben, wenn da Werbung dafür macht.
Inklusive unzensierter Hakenkreuzarmbindel.
Das ist doch alte News. Das hab ich doch schon im Podcast Lester-Schwestern gehört.
Und ich dachte, es geht hier darum, wie dumm der Hype um das Metaverse ist.
Was hat das jetzt mit einem Nazi-Gorilla zu tun?
Tja, auf der Website des Kongdo-Clubs, also der Gorilla-NFT-Kollektion, um die es hier geht, wird unter anderem damit geworben...
Das ist nicht der Bord-Alp-Jacht-Club. Das ist wieder was anderes, oder?
Alter, dieses NF-
Okay, weiter.
...dass der Hitchler-Gorilla ready ist fürs Metaverse.
Und das ist nur die Spitze des Eisbergs.
MontanaBlack musste sich nicht nur für den Hakenkreuz-Tweet entschuldigen,
sondern auch für Werbung für einen anderen NFT, der angeblich ein Scam sein soll, Squiggles.
Und was findet man auf der Squiggles-Webseite Metaverse-ready gegen?
Ich bin mir da noch nicht mal selbstsicher, ob der das aus eigenem Antrieb postet
oder ob er halt irgendwelche Beratungsleute hat, die sagen, hier, guck mal, was auch immer, keine Ahnung,
ob er da selbst immer auch drauf kommt.
Gut, nichtsdestotrotz, wenn sie unter seinem Account postet, dann mitgehangen, mitgefangen.
Unge hat Kritik dafür abbekommen, dass sie sich für über 40.000-
Dann machen die Berater den Job nicht gut, da wären sie nicht die ersten.
...1.000 Euro ein Azuki-Sen-NFT gekauft hat.
Und was ist das Azuki-Sen-Motto?
Eine Marke fürs Metaverse.
Eines der größten Metaverse-Projekte aktuell heißt Decentraland.
Die Währung da ist ein Krypto-
Wisst ihr, was ich da ein bisschen, ich hab mit überhaupt keine Schmerzen mit,
dass Leute Werbung machen, ja?
Null.
Und dass sie dafür ordentlich bezahlt werden, auch null.
Weil gerade, wenn du hunderttausende Viewer hast,
natürlich musst du ordentlich bezahlt werden.
Das ist nicht billig.
Also allein schon, wenn ich teilweise angucke, was ich,
und ich bin ja weit davon entfernt, sowas in dieser Richtung zu haben,
teilweise Angebote bekomme, ist schon nicht schlecht,
wobei ich vieles davon nicht mache.
Und wenn du umso größer du bist, umso krasser ist es.
Aber was ich bei dieser ganzen Werbung immer ein bisschen doof finde,
wenn das so quasi komplett ohne nachzugucken passiert.
Weil sowohl Unge als auch Montana Blackman,
wer auch sonst wie von den größeren Influencers,
die haben auch, gerade bei denen ist es so,
dass es da viele gibt, die die Sachen quasi fressen,
ohne sich irgendwie selbst Gedanken drüber zu machen.
Das sind gar nicht mal unbedingt, weil man immer sagt, das sind die Jüngere.
Ich würde mal sagen, es gibt genauso viele Jüngere,
die nicht richtig denken können wie Ältere.
Bei Älteren kommt dann halt noch die Erfahrung dazu,
dass sie irgendwann vielleicht mal feststellen,
okay, nicht jeder da sagt, er macht mich reich, macht mich auch wirklich reich.
Das muss man vielleicht auch erst mal lernen.
Aber das ist dann sehr viele Leute quasi fressen, diese Geschichte mit,
oh, geiles, ey, mit NFT, cooles Zeug und hier und da und da,
alles ganz toll und die Zukunft und sonst wie.
Obwohl die sich eigentlich selbst, außer,
dass die Montana Black oder Unge cool finden,
finden sie jetzt halt auch, NFT ist neuerdings geil.
So, warum? Keine Ahnung, weil es Montana Black oder Unge gepostet hat.
Die etwas Älteren, die blöd sind, haben vielleicht irgendwann mal schon gelernt,
dass es nicht so gut ist, jedem Nachzurenner sagt, er macht dich reich.
Aber deswegen denke ich halt, dass gerade Jüngere dafür empfänglich sind.
Wobei ich, wie gesagt, diese Sache, was immer erzählt wird,
ja, das sind immer Jüngere, die sind ja, als wären die Jüngeren blöder,
das würde ich so gar nicht mitgehen.
Ich würde sagen, es gibt genug schlaue Leute, die auch jünger sind.
Aber gerade was so Scams angeht und dass du nicht blind alles fressen darfst,
was irgendwelche Bezugspersonen oder wie man sie nennen mag, dir vorkauen,
das muss man wahrscheinlich mit Erfahrung, mit der Zeit auch ein bisschen lernen.
So, gucken wir mal.
Und die Grundstücke sind, you guessed it, NFTs.
Okay, aber was sind denn jetzt?
Das ist fast so geil wie dieser Scam, habe ich jetzt auch ein paar Mal gesehen.
Du kannst dir angeblich jetzt Land in Schottland kaufen,
also irgendwie so ein Quadratmeter Land in Schottland kannst du kaufen
und kannst dann dafür dir den Titel Lord oder Lady eintragen lassen,
was totaler Schwachsinn ist.
Das stimmt überhaupt nicht.
Also du besitzt weder dieses Land, also es ist nicht etwa so,
dass du da hingehen könntest und sagst, ich stelle mich jetzt auf mein Land drauf.
Kannst du nicht.
Diese Länder werden sogar shared, also diese Anbieter haben, keine Ahnung,
fünf Flächen und die werden dann mehrere Leute quasi verkauft.
Und das Einzige, was du bekommst, ist ein Zertifikat.
Du kannst dir nirgendswo diesen Titel eintragen lassen.
Es ist auch kein echter Titel.
Und wenn du es wirklich versuchen solltest, ist das Betrug.
Ja, also wenn du wirklich damit dann, wenn du wirklich draufschreiben solltest,
ist es wie, dass du irgendwie bei manchen irgendwie Doktor wirst
oder Prinz wirst oder was auch immer, so, weil du dir irgendwo was kriegst.
Wenn du versuchst, dir dann mit diesem Titel quasi noch was zu erschleichen,
das ist Betrug.
Und das Internet ist so krass voller Scams an allen Enden.
Und irgendwie haben es immer noch zu wenig Leute gecheckt.
Ich meine immerhin, Gott sei Dank, haben es die Leute,
und es ist jetzt ein bisschen weniger geworden,
haben es die Leute ja mittlerweile gecheckt,
dass wenn irgendein Typ mit einem fetten Auto um die Ecke gefahren kommt
und erst mal den hier macht, hier Leute, ich versuche mal kurz nachzumachen,
erst mal den hier macht, mit ein paar Geldscheinen aus dem Auto raus
und dann sagt, hier bei mir lernt ihr, wie ihr Reich wertet, nur ich weiß Bescheid.
Das haben die Leute glaube ich ja mittlerweile gecheckt,
dass das eher nicht so gut klappt, aber die restlichen Sachen klappen trotzdem noch.
Dieser Stream ist auch Scam.
Das hier ist die krasseste Abo-Falle, die ihr euch vorstellen könnt.
Nur mit dem Unterschied, dass ihr plus IQ-Punkte bekommt für jeden Sub.
Auch kein Scam, garantiert.
NFT steht für Non-Fungible Token.
Das heißt nicht austauschbar, einzigartig sozusagen.
Die Idee ist digitalen Dingen, die ja immer gleich kopierbar sind,
dieselbe Einzigartigkeit zu geben wie physischen Dingen.
Why? Because money.
Es gibt nur eine echte Monalisa, aber ein Foto von einer Monalisa kann ich...
Mit dem Unterschied, NFTs ist das, was das Wort sagt.
Das ist ein Token. Das ist irgendein Hash-Wert.
Das hat das erste Mal prinzipiell nichts damit zu tun, was man so an Grafiken sieht.
Es ist ja nicht so, als wäre irgendwie ein Affe da drinne gespeichert oder so.
Das kann ich beliebig oft kopieren, wenn ich aber in das Excel-Dokument reinschreibe,
dass mir...
Deswegen sind ja auch einige dieser ganzen angeblichen Krypto- und NFT-Projekte,
die es da so gibt.
Ich weiß nicht, inwieweit ihr das kennt. Ich will das nicht so sehr ausholen.
Es gibt ja die ein oder anderen Projekte, die zum Beispiel sagen, du kannst dir...
So Earth-2. Habt ihr Earth-2 mitbekommen?
Das ist ein Projekt, das verkauft dir virtuelles Land.
Also quasi so Blockchain-Krypto-NFT-Geschichten.
Da kannst du dir virtuelles Land kaufen. Da kannst du dir zum Beispiel England kaufen oder so was.
Man hat es davon abgesehen, das grundsätzliche Problem ist, dem gehört England nicht mal.
Da könnt ihr dir das verkaufen.
Also der verkauft dir quasi auf einer virtuellen Karte virtuelles Land.
Und das kannst du dir dann da kaufen.
So, und bei einigen dieser Projekten, dieser Projekte, die was von wegen Krypto- und NFT-
und Blockchain gefaselt haben, kamen jetzt im Endeffekt heraus,
diese Projekte sind eine ganz simple Postgres-Datenbank.
Nix Blockchain, nix NFT, nix Krypto.
Einfach eine stinknormale Postgres-Datenbank.
Wer hätte das so denken können, dass das Scam ist?
So. Also da ist beim Krypto gar nichts Krypto-erfielen, dieser Digger.
Aber die Leute stecken da Millionen teilweise rein. Das ist mir absolut...
Macht's, macht's wie ich, Leute.
Kauft euch von eurem Geld Stonks.
Und macht... Sekunde.
Und macht den letzten Monat über minus 1577,69 Euro minus.
Das ist sowas, das machen.
Okay, weiter.
... spezifische digitale Mona Lisa gehört, dann kann ich damit angeben gehen.
Kopieren kann man sie trotzdem noch, aber man kann angeben.
Und das ist tatsächlich der häufigste...
Wenn mal angenommen, die Mona Lisa wird es als NFT geben,
dann heißt das nichts, dass du dir das Ding mit nach Hause nehmen kannst.
Es heißt noch nicht mal, dass du...
irgendwie Sonderzutrittsrechte in den Raum hast, wo das hängt oder so.
Das heißt im Prinzip gar nichts.
Außer, dass du irgendwo im Internet steht, dass du die Mona Lisa hast.
Das ergibt...
Jetzt die Frage ist, was halt dranhängt.
Du kannst dann quasi beweisen, ja, du bist der Besitzer dieses Talkens.
Okay.
Aber welche Rechte mit diesem Talken verknüpft sind, ist ja die eigentliche Frage.
Und meistens gar keine.
Beziehungsweise Sachen, die andere nicht können.
Es ergibt so keinen Sinn, wie es aktuell ist, außer um die Leute zu scammen.
... anwendungsbereich von NFTs.
Rechte überträgt man damit übrigens nicht, wie in diesem Fall von einem Froscharsch,
den ein Künstler als NFT verkauft hat.
Aber weil er weiterhin das Urheberrecht am Bild hatte,
konnte er noch mehr Froscharsch-NFTs daraus machen,
was den Typen, der den Froscharsch für eine halbe Million gekauft hat...
Was? Eine halbe Million, Alter?
... gefallen hat. Und das, Kinder, sind NFTs.
Kann man nicht mehrere Talkens für ein Objekt erstellen?
Natürlich kannst du das.
Du kannst so viele Talkens erstellen, wie du lustig bist,
weil das Talken erst mal mit dem Bild absolut gar nichts zu tun hat.
Eine Besitzurkunde ist was anderes.
Eine Besitzurkunde bedeutet ja auch wirklich, dass sie das Ding gehört.
Also da könntest du das wahrscheinlich, solange du nicht vertraglich irgendwelche Verbindungen eingehst.
Also wenn du mit dem Museum einen Vertrag unterschrieben hast,
dass du ihnen das für ein halbes Jahr zur Ausstellung überlässt,
dann kannst du sie nicht einfach abhängen.
Aber ansonsten kannst du das einpacken, mitnehmen und bei dir daheim hinhängen, wenn dir das gehört.
Wenn du Besitzer davon bist, wirklich von diesem Gemälde,
kannst du das machen, was du bei einem NFT nicht machen kannst.
Weil das Einzige, was dir wirklich gehört bei einem NFT,
ist im Endeffekt der Hashwert, der Talken.
Und nachdem das Bild erst mal nichts mit dem Talken zu tun hat,
ist das ziemlich unsinnig.
Deswegen kann ich auch auf irgendeine x-beliebige Filesharing-Seite gehen
und mir alle Affen-NFTs runterladen.
Die habe ich dann, die kann ich in meinem Twitter-Avatar machen oder sonst wo.
Wo es anfängt interessant zu werden,
wobei man sagen muss, da ist dann aber auch fraglich, ob das Crypto-Blockchain-NFT sein muss.
Wo es anfängt interessant zu werden, aber soweit sind wir irgendwie witzigerweise nicht,
weil die Leute ja erst mal gescannt werden müssen.
Wo es anfängt interessant zu werden, ist,
wenn du diese Tokens quasi als Ausweis verwendest
und Anbieter dann quasi darauf aufsetzend Sachen implementieren.
Also zum Beispiel, wenn jetzt YouTube sagt oder Twitter,
Twitter macht ja sowas teilweise schon,
wenn YouTube und Twitter beispielsweise eine Avatar-Funktion einbaut,
wo du checken kannst, wo du es verbinden kannst mit irgendwelchen Blockchains,
frag mir nicht genau, wie man das machen würde,
und dann gecheckt wird so nach dem Motto,
ok, der Account-Besitzer hat sich quasi authentifiziert,
dass er quasi, dass dieses Wallet oder ich weiß gar nicht, wie man das da genau nennt,
Twitter hat sowas mittlerweile, dass das diesem Account-Besitzer zugeordnet werden kann
und dort ist dann quasi hinterlegt, dass der das und das gekauft hat
und aufgrund dessen zeigen wir jetzt Avatar XY an.
Sowas in der Richtung mit Integration.
Ja, aber das bedeutet noch lange nicht, dass dann in diesem Token das gespeichert ist,
sondern nur, dass der Anbieter was zusätzliches anzeigt aufgrund diesem Token.
Also das eine hat mit dem anderen gar nicht so viel zu tun.
Das ist dann wieder eine Implementierungsfrage.
Neue Gold Rush aus den letzten Monaten, der dazu geführt hat,
dass jeder jetzt alles als NFT verkaufen will,
zum Beispiel die Associated Press, die dachte es wäre super hip,
Bilder von Geflüchteten kurz vorm Ersaufen als NFT anzubieten.
Was?
Oder mein persönlicher Lieblings-NFT-Diggi.
Seriously, das gab es?
Also da müsste doch glaube ich auch, also wenn der Typ,
der hinter diesem Twitter-Account steht,
der muss doch beim Schreiben dieser Meldung irgendwie in hinteren,
ganz tief hinten in seinem Hirn,
muss doch irgendjemand so eine innere Stimme gesagt haben,
das ist wahrscheinlich keine gute Idee.
Aber anscheinend nicht.
Anscheinend nicht.
Oder mein persönlicher Lieblings-NFT-Digitale-Fürze,
weil die Influencerin, die vorher ihre Fürze in echt abgefüllt
und verkauft hat, davon krank wurde,
dass sie für die Fürze so ungesund essen musste.
Das ist ja noch besser als Gamer Girl Badewasser.
Das wird ja immer schlimmer, Alter.
Es wird ja immer schlimmer.
Sag mal, Chat, ich hab den Eindruck,
wir sind die einzige High-IQ Bastion,
die es im Internet noch gibt, wenn ich mir diesen Scheiß angucke.
Deswegen gucken in letzter Zeit auch so viele Leute zu,
weil hier High-IQ-Leute unter sich sind.
Keine Ahnung, aber ganz ehrlich, du zweifelst doch wirklich.
Also nicht nur am Verstand.
Der Leute am Verstand zweifel ich ja schon länger.
Aber auch an allen sonstigen Skills der Menschheit so langsam, oder?
Das ist doch als nicht mehr normal.
Dass es die jetzt nur noch digital gibt.
Okay, aber das klingt doch echt ziemlich dumm.
Das kann doch nicht lange gut gehen.
Okay.
Es wirkt also inzwischen ein bisschen so,
als wäre die Stimmung zu Krypto und zu NFTs
ein bisschen gekippt.
Es reicht nicht mehr, dass man mit NFTs nur angeben kann.
Einfach irgendwo einen Eintrag zu haben,
der sagt, dass man etwas besitzt,
ist nicht genug, um zu garantieren, dass der Preis immer weiter steigt.
Aber was?
Wenn es einen mystischen digitalen Ort gäbe,
wo ich meine NFTs tatsächlich nutzen kann,
ein Ort, der mehr ist als eine Online-Tauschbörse für JPEG.
Ach, stimmt.
Er will ja den Überleitung zum Metaverse machen.
Wundersamer Platz, wo ich meine digitale Kunst
auch tatsächlich ausstellen kann, wie in einem eigenen Haus.
Wow!
Herzlich willkommen zu dem Grund,
warum das Metaverse in der Kryptokommunikation halbt wird.
Das ist einfach, um mehr NFTs zu verkaufen.
Ja, aber daran sieht man schon mal,
das ist, glaube ich, eine ziemlich gute Erklärung an der Stelle,
woran man sieht, dass das eigentliche Taupen
mit dem, was man im Kopf damit verknüpft, gar nichts zu tun hat.
Weil, den Talken kannst du heute schon,
also du kannst die Sachen heute schon, ich nenne es mal, erwerben,
aber irgendjemand muss erst hingehen, sich hinsetzen,
einen Metaverse programmieren, Content dafür erstellen,
dass du mit deinen Talkens dann darin was anzeigen kannst.
Also daran sieht man, dass das eine mit dem anderen
erst einmal gar nichts zu tun hat.
Weil ansonsten könnte ich das erste ja nicht schon kaufen,
während das andere vielleicht irgendwann mal da ist.
Ja, aber was ist das Metaverse?
Oh, das ist einfach.
Ich habe da nämlich neulich ein paar Überschriften gesehen,
wie Kaufland mit seiner eigenen Insel ins Metaverse startet.
Kaufland treibt die Expansion des Handels ins Metaverse.
Ja, das ist, das ist wie damals BMW auch irgendeine Filiale
in Second Life aufgemacht hat,
weil irgendein Manager damals mitbekommen hat, das ist hip
und dabei war es eigentlich schon überhaupt nicht mehr hip.
Wow, also ich wusste überhaupt nicht,
dass wir schon so weit sind beim Metaverse.
Das gibt es schon? Und Kaufland ist da?
Äh, nee, ist doch nicht.
Ja, Kaufland hat einfach eine Twitch-Streamerin bezahlt,
ihnen eine Insel im Spiel Animal Crossing New Horizons zu bauen.
Die Agentur, die sich das...
Alter, also, jetzt warst du ernsthaft.
Um aus der eigentlichen Nachricht diese Überschrift zu machen,
da musst du schon, da musst schon weit,
weit die großen Gedanken sprung machen, ja?
Nee, ist doch nicht.
Äh, ja, Kaufland hat einfach eine Twitch-Streamerin bezahlt,
ihnen eine Insel im Spiel Animal Crossing New Horizons zu bauen.
Die Agentur, die sich das ausgedacht hat,
hat einfach gesagt, das wäre das Metaverse.
Da musst du schon, da musst du schon wirklich
absolute Elevenheader sein,
um von einer Animal Crossing Insel zu Metaverse,
äh, Kaufland hat einen Metaverse-Stunt.
Medien, das völlig unkritisch übernommen.
Ich mein, nix gegen Animal Crossing.
Ist ein tolles Spiel, aber es ist eine Sache auf keinen Fall.
Das Metaverse, das ist einfach nur ein Spiel,
das nicht mal VR kann, mit ein bisschen gestalterischer Freiheit.
Das ist ein bisschen so, als würde ich...
Und ein Spiel, wohlgemerkt, wohlgemerkt,
mit einem kacke Online-Modus.
Nintendo-Style, verschissene Multiplayer.
Also, das ist, wenn es einen mit,
dann ist es auch im Kernaspekt, nämlich Online- und Multiplayer,
ein äußerst, äußerst schlechtes Metaverse.
Jetzt ein Charakter erstellen, den Robb Bubble nennen
und dann eine Pressemitteilung raushauen.
Robb Bubble ist der erste YouTuber im Metaverse.
Auf geht's. Boah, krass.
Warte mal, heißt das... heißt das,
dass vieles über das Metaverse aktuell Bullshit ist?
Was? Ich hab jetzt schon mal ein ganzes erspartes Geld
in Metaverse-Ready-NFTs gesteckt.
Äh... Ihr müsst mal kurz Werbung machen, sorry.
Kennen Sie das?
Sie haben das gesamte ersparte Geld Ihrer Familie
in wertlose NFTs gesteckt, aber dann kam das Metaverse gar nicht
und jetzt müssen Sie vor Ihrer wütenden Frau ins Ausland fliehen?
Aber ich hab doch überhaupt nicht genug Geld,
um das Land zu verlassen.
Gar kein Problem. Mit NordVPN können Sie einfach so tun,
als wären Sie in einem anderen Land.
Ich bin gerade in Amerika. Oh nein, ernsthaft?
Das ist ja viel geiler als das Metaverse.
Es gibt sogar schon Content, der existiert und fertig ist.
Muss es NordVPN sein, wirklich, ja?
Die wegen Geoblocking hier sonst gar nicht verfügbar wären.
Und ich kann dann NordVPN in meinem D-Land von meiner Frau verstecken,
dass ich gerade schon wieder auf LFD-Plattform bin.
Was machst du da?
Äh, nix. NordVPN ist aber eine der schnellsten VPNs überhaupt
und funktioniert auf allen Geräten.
Auch für meine MetaQuest 2?
Nein, dafür ist es aber auf dem Handy und auf bis zu sechs Geräten
gleichzeitig nutzbar.
Der integrierte NordVPN-Bedrohungsschutz kann außerdem dabei helfen,
dass z.B. die Werbetracker und überhaupts blockiert werden.
Zumindest, ähm, eine Sache funktioniert ja bei den VPN-Dingern wirklich.
Du kannst damit höchstwahrscheinlich, bis die Anbieter wieder rumdricksen,
Geoblocking umgehen. Okay, ja, das ist richtig.
Der Rest ist Blödsinn. Also, die schützen dich weder
gescheit vor Online-Trackern, wie sollen sie das machen,
äh, noch schützen sie dich irgendwie vor Werbung
oder noch schützen sie dich vor Schadsoftware.
Wie soll es auch funktionieren? Ich meine, dein Stream ist
end-zu-ende verschlüsselt über HTTPS.
Wir können da gar nicht reingucken.
Herzlich willkommen, slash, Robbubble.
Kriegt ihr den 2-Jahresplan mit einem riesigen Rabatt,
inklusive einem kostenlosen Monat, das sind nur 2,77 Euro monatlich.
Probiert das ohne Risiko mal aus, dank der 30-Tage.
Die machen DNS-App-Blocking. Ja, das geht.
Das ist auch das Einzige, was mir einfällt, was funktionieren könnte.
Fiction-Roman namens Snowcrash, der erst 30 Jahre alt ist.
Und letztendlich ist es... Die machen Man in the Middle-Gedöns.
Wie sollen die Man in the Middle machen mit einer HTTPS-Verbindung
zu, keine Ahnung, zum Google-Web-Server?
Die können bestimmt nicht Man in the Middle für einen Google-Web-Server machen.
Und wenn, dann würde ich mir ernsthafte Gedanken machen.
Ein bisschen MMORPG wie World of Warcraft, aber mit beliebigen Avataren.
Und ein ganz schlechter Avatar vom Zuck auf...
Ich fand diese... Habt ihr auch diese vom Zuckerberg,
oder vom Zuckerberg, muss man ja sagen,
die diese Metaverse-Geschichte gesehen,
wo er da mit seinem 3D-Avatar herumgerannt ist?
Ich fand das so zum Fremdschem, und das hat sich so...
So wirr angefühlt, so irgendwie...
Was will er uns eigentlich damit sagen?
Und warum sollte ich das benutzen wollen?
Und was ist das überhaupt, was du mir hier zeigen willst?
Das hier meine ich...
Ja, genau, das hier meine ich, ja.
Moment, da war Tracer drin? Wirklich?
Kann ich mich gar nicht dran erinnern.
Mit einem digitalen Charakter wie in Fortnite.
Oder eben wie in Hitler-Gorilla.
Was übrigens der Grund ist, warum vor ein paar Jahren Leute gesagt haben,
Fortnite wäre das Metaverse, weil man da als Darth Vader neben Deadpool,
neben Charakteren aus Dune rumrennen kann.
Oh, da ist das Metaverse. Na ja, wenn es danach geht,
wenn es danach geht, ist jedes MMO das Metaverse.
Keine Ahnung.
Das ist wieder so ein Passwort, wo keiner so...
Was gar nicht richtig griffig und greifbar ist,
das hat irgendjemand sich jetzt ausgedacht,
und jetzt kann man machen, was man will.
Das Metaverse ist aber eigentlich nicht nur als Spiel gedacht,
sondern auch für Arbeitsmeetings zum Treffen von Freunden.
Oh, da gibt es was Cooles.
Das möchte bei mir auf der Arbeit keiner haben,
aber ich fände es geil, wenn wir es hätten.
Work Adventure?
Das da?
Nee.
Ach Mensch, wie heißt das?
Oder doch?
Wo du so einen Pixel... Doch, genau das.
Das finde ich so nice.
Wo du in so einer Pixelwelt rumlaufen kannst,
und wenn du dann in den Raum reingehst zu einer Besprechung,
dann geht der Voice Chat an.
Das finde ich cool.
Aber das hat keine Integration mit Teams,
und dementsprechend keine Chance bei uns.
Da sind wir, glaube ich, auch nicht agil dafür.
...Events und als grundlegender Ersatz für Social Media
und das gesamte Internet und dann am besten auch noch...
Okay, Chat, ich muss mal kurz meiner Informationspflicht nachkommen im Chat.
Magst du, das wäre aus deiner Sicht ein Gehaltsniveau,
unter dem man als Fachinformatiker Systemintegration nicht einsteigen sollte?
Kommt auf die Region an,
was du...
in welchem Bereich du aktiv bist.
Also, das ist schwer zu sagen.
Fachinformatiker Systemintegration kann ja von Cloud-Gedöns
bis zu Druckerpatronen tauschen, alles sein.
Aber ich sag mal, unter 40k würde ich es nicht machen.
Wenn ich jetzt pauschal irgendeine Zahl sagen müsste.
Aber ansonsten ist das schwer zu beantworten jetzt.
Ja, Laravel kenne ich.
Das war vor ein paar Jahren schon ziemlich gut
und ist wahrscheinlich jetzt noch besser.
PAP ist halt PAP, aber mit Laravel ist es ganz gut.
Symphonie, keine Ahnung.
In Virtual Reality und Augmented Reality,
also quasi alles, was wir bisher digital machen,
soll verschmelzen in einer virtuellen Welt.
Und wir haben dabei ein Headset auf,
was uns komplett eintauchen lässt.
Also quasi das Internet in 3D sozusagen.
Und ja, ihr habt das gerade richtig gehört.
Leute, ich predikte mal was.
Ihr wisst insgeheim, dass ich recht habe.
Ich predikte jetzt mal was.
Sollte wirklich irgendjemand so eine Art VR-Chat-Metaverse
technisch starten, wisst ihr,
was der erste Content ist, den es darin geben wird?
Und ihr wisst, dass ich recht habe?
Das ist gut, Phipps.
Korrekt!
Das ist das erste, was es geben wird.
Tausendprozentig.
Das ist klar.
Ich meine, man muss sich mal überlegen,
sei es jetzt VHS-Videotapes oder DVDs,
oder was auch immer.
Der ganze Kram oder auch VR-Brillen-Gedöns,
das hat sich durchgesetzt zuerst im Pornbereich.
Und das ist das erste, was es da geben wird.
Ich meine, es ist jetzt ja teilweise schon ultra abgedreht.
Wusstet ihr, wusstet ihr,
dass es in Final Fantasy X online ist,
das MMO, das war ich auch mal mit dem Friseur eine Weile gespielt habe.
Dass du dir in Final Fantasy XIV
über externe Seiten,
also in Game gibt es dafür noch keinen Marketplace,
kannst du dir z.B.
Chat,
Catgirl-Chat-Zeit buchen.
Also da gehst du auf irgendeine Seite,
suchst dir was raus, suchst dir das Game aus
und dann kannst du dir dann buchen mit irgendwer.
Müssen nicht Catgirls, alles Mögliche,
was es halt so gibt in Final Fantasy XIV.
Da kannst du dann quasi...
Nee, nee, Epel, das ist ja noch halbwegs seriös,
nennen wir es mal, ja.
Aber dann kannst du wirklich dort
erotische In-Game-Chats buchen in Final Fantasy XIV.
Also man sieht schon, die Ansätze sind da.
Und wenn zwar sowas wie Metaverse
in der Richtung, wie sie sich das vorstellen, gibt,
ähm...
Ja, natürlich gibt es das in WoW auch.
Aber ich glaube, dass Final Fantasy XIV
durch den Weep-Faktor
noch mal beliebter ist.
Und es ist das klar, dass es das als Allererstes gibt.
Arbeit soll auch ein Teil davon sein.
Firmen wie Microsoft und Facebook aka Meta
denken, wir haben tatsächlich bald Meetings
mit unseren lustigen Avataren im Metaverse.
Danke, dass Sie alle zu den Meetings gekommen sind.
Sie sehen, es sieht aktuell nicht gut aus.
Wir brauchen kreative Ideen.
Johnson, was haben Sie mitgebracht?
Ja, vielen Dank.
Also wie Sie sehen können,
haben wir die KPIs in Q2 leider nicht erreicht.
Entschuldigen Sie, Johnson, ich möchte Sie nicht unterbrechen,
aber ist das ein offizieller Gorilla-NFT
aus der Hitler-Kollektion?
Ja, ich dachte, wenn der Chef schon kommt,
dann ziehe ich auch immer einfach das Teuerste an,
was ich so habe.
Ich meine, wer hat nicht Bock, nach zwei Jahren Zoom-Meetings
bald acht Stunden am Tag ein schweres Headset aufzuhaben,
mit dem man nicht mal richtig zwischendurch
ganz scharf drauf ist.
Übrigens, Unfälle wegen VR-Headsets sind letztes Jahr...
Nein, die richtig coolen Headsets,
die haben ja noch mal Kamera vorne drauf.
Dann kannst du dann quasi das Echte
noch mal durchsehen oder so.
Ja, um 31% gestiegen.
Also, sprechen wir jetzt mal über all meine Gründe,
warum der aktuelle Hype um das Metaverse,
meiner Meinung nach, richtig dumm ist.
Grund eins, es gibt nicht...
Ich muss ehrlich sagen,
ich spüre den Hype um das Metaverse
jetzt nicht.
Vielleicht bin ich auch nicht in den passenden
Bubbles unterwegs.
Aber ich merke, ich spüre...
Spürt ihr den Hype ums Metaverse?
Hast du gesehen, wo der Zock in einem Krisengebiet
mit seinem Arm hat? Nein, habe ich nicht.
Also ich spüre den Hype um das Metaverse nicht.
Das eine Metaverse.
Da gibt es die Centraland, wo jemand
für 2,4 Millionen ein einziges
Grundstück gekauft hat.
The Sandbox, wo jemand 450.000 Dollar
ausgegeben hat, um Snoop Doggs virtueller
Nachbar zu werden und wo Adidas
ja, wie gesagt, Earth 2 ist auch
in der Richtung Neisser Scam
Teekleidung verkaufen will.
Wenn euch das wundert, es gibt auch schon
digitales Bier und Chicken Wings,
die ich dann anscheinend zusammen mit meinem
Furz-NFT genießen kann.
Keine Ahnung, wie das funktionieren soll.
Dann gibt es natürlich noch Horizon Worlds
von Mark Zuckerberg.
Und dann noch weniger große Projekte,
wie Cryptovoxel, Somnium Space, Nifty Island,
Blocktopia oder jetzt bald
vermutlich Other Side.
Das Metaverse von Vort A...
So was wie VR Chat gibt es schon
ganz lange und ist auch relativ
beliebt seit Jahren schon.
Yacht Club, dem erfolgreichsten
NFT überhaupt, das ist der mit den Schimpansen.
Nicht zu verwechseln mit dem
Mittler-Gorilla. Das Problem ist,
die basieren teilweise auch völlig unter...
Die Sache ist halt die...
Was ich
bei den Bort
Ape Zeug noch nicht mal verstehe ist,
die Dinger sehen
auch nicht mal gut aus.
Also es ist nicht mal,
dass ich sagen würde, oh hier,
künstlerisch so
toll, das sind Randomized
aus, keine Ahnung, 12
verschiedenen
States und
also...
und die Dinger sehen auch nicht mal gut aus.
Nicht zu verwechseln mit dem mit dem
Mittler-Gorilla. Das Problem ist, die
basieren teilweise auf völlig unterschiedlichen
Technologien. Bei Horizon Worlds geht es
zum Beispiel bisher gar nicht um NFTs,
wie in allen anderen Projekten. Also wenn Meta hier gewinnt
und das Metaverse baut,
kann es sein, dass ich meinen Mittler-Gorilla
nie benutzen kann. Und wenn ich für
450.000 Euro in The Sandbox mein Grundstück
habe, die Centraland aber die führende
Plattform wird, habe ich auch.
Und das nimmt ja schon an, dass sich überhaupt
eine durchsetzt in einer Welt, wo PC,
Xbox, Playstation, Nintendo, Switch
alle ihre Berechtigung haben, wo ich Zoom, Google
Meet, Discord, Teams, Skype,
alle gleichzeitig installiert haben muss, weil jeder irgendwas anderes
nutzt. Wenn ich Metaverse Fan
bin, muss ich vermutlich meine
fünf Plattformen am Tag abklappern
und mein teures Grundstück in jeder einzelnen
pflegen. Hier mal Rasen mähen, da die Blumen gießen.
Ich meine, das soll ja auch ein bisschen realistisch sein, ne?
Grund zwei, ein gutes MMO zu bauen,
ist verdammt schwierig. Star Citizen
ist ein Weltraum. Die Sache ist halt
die, was die glaube ich alle irgendwie nicht so ganz
auf dem Schirm haben.
Zumindest habe ich in der Richtung nichts gesehen.
Warum sollte man in diese Spielwelt
gehen?
Ich meine, warum sollte ich in die Spielwelt gehen,
wenn es einfach nur mehr
oder weniger genauso lame ist, wie die echte
Welt? Also wo ist der Sinn?
Bei MMO,
RPGs, irgendwelche Fantasy-Dinger,
da verstehe ich das. Da level ich meinen Character,
da mache ich irgendwelche Raids, da
crafte ich irgendwas, da erkunde ich die Welt
und sonst was. Das sehe ich bei
diesen ganzen Metaverse-Geschichten nicht.
In VR-Chat noch am ehesten,
wobei da glaube ich auch
user-generated-content ganz
großes. Also
ich verstehe es
nicht so wirklich, ja.
Und das seit über zehn Jahren in
Entwicklung ist. Es hat seitdem über 400
Millionen Dollar gesammelt. Ungefähr
genauso viel Geld wie Juga Labs, die Firma
hinter dem Metaverse Otherside,
dem Board Ape Yacht Club und Crypto Punks.
Das Ding ist, Star Citizen
ist viel weniger aufwendig als
ein Metaverse und das kann nicht mal
VR. Und da arbeitet ein Team
aus 600 Leuten,
die ihre ganze bisherige Karriere lang
Videospiele gebaut haben, seit
zehn Jahren dran. Trotzdem ist die Chance
relativ groß, dass Star Citizen
niemals wirklich erscheinen wird.
Ich glaube für die meisten
Sachen nicht so das
beste Beispiel.
Juga Labs hingegen hat
elf Angestellte. Elf.
Und keiner von denen hat, soweit ich weiß,
Erfahrung in der Programmierung. Das ist ja normal.
Die ganzen NFTs-Scam-Games werden
nie echte Games werden.
Die verkaufen jetzt schon irgendwie so nach dem Motto
jetzt früh sichert euch ganz schnell
irgendwie virtuelles Land, macht hier
unser, wenn wir dann releasen, dann
kommt da was. Aber jetzt ist nie
gedacht, was zu releasen. Das ist gedacht, jetzt
Kohle abzugreifen und dann mit der Kohle sich zu verpissen.
Trotzdem hat denen jemand
450 Millionen Dollar für die
Entwicklung eines Videospiels gegeben.
Leute, wisst ihr wie viele...
Das ist ja einfach zu erklären.
Das erinnert mich an das Beispiel
damals aus so 2000
rum zur.com Zeit
bei der.com Bubble.
Da hat ein Bauer,
der Kartoffel angebaut hat,
der hat ein Unternehmen gegründet
und hat dem irgendeinen futuristischen
.net
Internet Namen gegeben.
Und die wollten dem Bauer allen
Ernstes Millionen Kapital
geben, bis dann irgendwann mal rauskommen,
dass das Typ ist ein Bauer, der Kartoffel anbaut, der hat
mit Internet und Technologie überhaupt nichts am Hut.
Und so ähnlich stelle ich mir das da auch vor.
Das wird nicht weiter hinterfragt.
So nach dem Motto, boah alter krass
Metaverse Shit hier, frisst mein
Geld, nimm.
Videospiele einfach abgrundtief
Scheiße sind und dann nur
noch ein MMO, Amazon,
der riesige Internet Konzern mit unendlich
vielen Ressourcen, die keine gescheiten Spiele aufnehmen,
hat letztes Jahr mit New World sein erstes
MMO rausgebildet.
Ja, nur mit dem Unterschied,
dass Amazon
nicht weiß, was sie machen.
Keine Ahnung, also
Amazon, die entwickeln seit Jahren irgendwelche Games,
haben kaum was released, das was sie released
haben war Schrott
und dann kam New World raus, von dem
absehbar war, dass es Schrott wird
und genau in den Bereichen Schrott
geworden ist, wo man ihm prophezeit hat,
dass es Schrott wird, ja
By the way,
Moment, Moment, Sekunde, ich hab's so irgendwo hier.
Wie sieht's aus?
Ah, yes!
Das ist so schlecht,
guckt euch das mal an, 20k
Peak von 913.000
500 Millionen Dollar pro
Jahr, nicht insgesamt,
für Spielentwicklung aus.
Was die damit machen, ist mir unbegreiflich.
Also was Amazon
mit ihrem Geld macht, ist mir komplett
unverständlich. Weiß einfach vorher selten,
ob ein MMO langfristig
erfolgreich ist und trotzdem
geben Leute Millionen
von Dollar aus für Gegenstände
in Spielen, die es noch nicht mal wirklich
gibt. Guckt euch mal die Grafik an,
von The Central Land.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass viele das machen,
weil sie hoffen,
nicht, weil sie wirklich an das Spiel glauben
oder so, die hoffen, dass sie das noch teurer
verkaufen können und sich dann wieder vom Acker machen.
Was anderes,
wer glaubt denn ernsthaft daran, dass aus diesen ganzen
NFT-Kryptogames irgendwann mal
ein spielenswertes Game wird?
Es ist eher umgedreht.
Sobald ein Game anfängt, was von NFT
und Kryptogramm zu erzählen,
gehe ich eher davon aus,
dass das Game nie ein gescheites Game wird.
Also es ist genau umgedreht.
Es ist nicht so, dass jetzt einer sagt,
NFT-Krypto und ich sag, boah, cooles Game,
sondern eher ich sag vielleicht, oh cooles Game
und dann sagt der NFT-Krypto und ich sag,
ok und Tschüss.
Das ist ein Bild, das ist, haben die
selbst gepostet. Das sieht, das sieht aus,
das sieht aus wie
Wii-Avatare oder
Xbox 360-Avatare nur in schlecht.
Das ist,
das ist ihre beste Eindruck, den sie
machen konnten. Das hier ist ein
offizielles Video von Meta,
von deren Website.
Boah.
Und jetzt stell dir mal vor,
du bist in einem Meeting, was so aussieht
und falls ihr euch gerade fragt, so
hä, das sieht doch einfach aus wie ein
20 Jahre altes Computerspiel. Das sieht aus
wie Sims, nur in schlecht. Was ist da jetzt
der Unterschied?
Es gibt keinen, außer dass Computerspiele
tatsächlich eine Story haben und coole
Quests, mit denen man Abenteuer erleben kann.
Nichts hat jemals irgendjemanden
davon abgehalten, ein Business-Meeting
oder Forecraft zu veranstalten. Es ist
halt einfach nur eine dumme Idee.
Grund drei, deine NFT-Items
wird's nie geben. Warum?
Ich fände das nice. Ich fände die ganze Zeit
Witze über den Hitler-Gorilla fürs Metaverse,
weil die Idee einfach lächerlich ist.
Aber auch bei anderen Items
stellt sich ja die Frage, wenn ich
jetzt einem NFT-Projekt sehr
viel Geld gebe für ein Bild
in der Blockchain, dann
Das Bild ist ja noch nicht mal
in der Blockchain. Die das gemacht hat ja
von allem mein Geld, aber hatte bisher
lächerlich wenig Arbeit, die musste nur einen JPEG
malen. Dieses JPEG dann später
aber in 3D zu modellieren,
das zu riggen, dann die Blockchain
in das Metaverse in einer Wahl zu integrieren,
obwohl es da vielleicht gar keine Schnittstelle gibt
und das dann regelmäßig mit Updates zu
versorgen, weil das Metaverse ja auch immer wieder geupdatet wird,
das kostet unglaublich viele
Ressourcen. Aber ich hab ja schon alles dafür
bezahlt. Also welche Motivation
sollte irgendjemand haben, diese
Metaverse-Ready-Items?
Nee, die nicht.
Die haben eher Interesse daran, ihren eigenen Shit
zu verkaufen.
Auch tatsächlich herzustellen,
nachdem er schon durch mich
Multi-Millionär geworden ist. Mal abgesehen davon,
dass die Leute, die aktuell die ganzen NFTs
anbieten, meistens gar keine Programmierer sind
und mal abgesehen davon, ob jemand
wie Meta einen Hitler-Gorilla
zulassen würde, obwohl
vielleicht ist die
Animation dann noch ein extra,
quasi ein DLC-NFT.
Rechtsextreme Affen.
Grund 4. Das Metaverse ist eine dystopische
Horrorwelt, in der keiner leben will.
Das Metaverse will nicht nur
unser Social Media sein, sondern auch unsere Spiele,
unser Entertainment, unsere Meetings,
also quasi Roblox-Arbeit.
Es gibt ein Riesenproblem damit, wenn unser
gesamtes Leben von einer einzigen
Plattform abhängt und nochmal extra,
wenn dann dahinter irgendwas Seltsames
wie NFTs oder Kryptos steckt und
alles zu Geld gemacht werden soll. Mal abgesehen
davon, dass ein Metaverse, was tatsächlich
geil ist, auch super
gefährlich wäre, weil Leute dann kein
echtes Leben mehr leben wollen. Social
Media macht uns jetzt auch schon richtig.
Und dann haben wir auch noch Mark Zuckerberg
Da haben wir uns glaube ich wenig Gedanken zu machen.
Das haben wir, was weiß ich, das wird ja
immer wieder prophezeit, auch bei MMOs. Aber ganz nach
und abgesehen, es wird kein Metaverse geben,
wo die Leute 24-7 drin sein wollen.
Als perfekten Sci-Fi-Bösewicht.
Nicht jeder will, dass sein Social Media Profil
mit all diesen anderen Erfahrungen verbunden ist. Und ich
und das Internet. Ja, I get that.
Deswegen macht es mit eurem
Facebook-Account viel besser.
Das bringt schon jetzt das Schlimmste in unserer Gesellschaft an's Tageslicht.
Horizon Worlds ist
noch nicht mal wirklich draußen und schon jetzt
gab es Fälle, wo Frauen
digital befummelt wurden. Das ist kein
Witz, dass so oft passiert. Ja, das wundert mich nicht. In Horizon Worlds
gibt es deswegen inzwischen eine Arme Länge Abstand.
Okay, also ist das Metaverse
Bullshit. Das..oh mann.
Ich und das
überrascht euch jetzt vielleicht. Ich, ich. Liebe VR.
Ich zweifle echt an der gesamten menschheit langsam. Ich habe eine menge spaß mit
der Oculus beziehungsweise der Meta Quest, aber nicht für mehr als eine stunde immer
mal wieder. Ich bin aber offen dafür zu sehen, wo die Technologie hingeht und ich
freue mich auch drauf, weil ich finde es ziemlich krass, was schon möglich ist.
Aber als jemand, der ein VR-Helz zu hause hat und seit 20 Jahren als einziges
Hobby Videospiele spielt, weiß ich, wenn das Metaverse kommt, dann sind wir noch
Jahre davon entfernt. Leute, die jetzt investieren, sind viel zu früh. Vor 20
Jahren in der Dotcom-Blase haben Leute auch festgestellt, korrekt, dass das
Internet das nächste größte Ding ist und dann haben sie alle in die dümmsten
Firmen investiert und alle Geld verloren. Ja, zum Beispiel Bauern mit Kartoffeln und
ja auch das Metaverse. Da sind für mich überall Visionen drin. PC kann ich dir
gleich zeigen. Was tatsächlich Sinn machen könnte und auch sehr cool sein könnte, könnte. Noch gibt
es das nicht und viele von den Visionen, die es gibt, sind absolut schrecklich.
Noch ist das überhaupt nicht cool. Kleiner Fun-Fact am Rande. 1929 hat der
Vater von John F. Kennedy angeblich den größten Börsencrash der Geschichte
vorhersagen können, weil ein Junge, der ihm die Schuhe poliert hat, angefangen
hat ihm Aktientipps zu geben und das für ihn ein absolut klares Zeichen war, dass
hier Leute am spekulieren waren, die absolut keine Ahnung von Finanzmärkten
hatten und er hat daraufhin all seine Aktien verkauft und den Crash überlebt.
Wenn wir das jetzt 100 Jahre später über... Naja gut, also jetzt bei ernsthaft.
Irgendeine Anekdote, wo irgendeiner mal was richtiges gemacht hat und Millionen
Leute, die es falsch gemacht haben. Also das kann ja alle möglich sein. Das kann im
Endeffekt einfach nur Glück gewesen sein....setzen. Wer sich einen Hitler-Gorilla
kauft in der Hoffnung, dass er den mal als Kostüm in einem neuen 3D-Facebook
anziehen kann, was es noch gar nicht gibt, von dem würde ich keine
Finanztipps annehmen und vielleicht auch generell gar keine... Wie gesagt,
Finanztipps solltet ihr von mir annehmen.
Im letzten Monat minus 1577 Euro und 69 Cent. Da kannst du eigentlich nix
Besseres machen mehr.
Stonks, ja. Massive Stonks.
Zeigt ihr Po? Nö.
Da gibt's nicht viel zu zeigen.
Wie geht's den Amazon-Aktien? Hat sich nicht viel getan.
Es ist immer noch ähnlich zu dem, wo ich es gekauft habe.
Das ist minimal hoch, aber nicht viel. Und ich habe Hunger.
Ich bin 3 Stunden 33 schon. Und das ist ja für meine Verhältnisse schon
ziemlich lang. Ja, es gibt Leute, die können 8 Stunden am Tag streamen.
Ich weiß nicht, wie die das machen. Ich verstehe es nicht.
Ich wäre Heiser, wenn ich mehrfach die Woche 8 Stunden streamen würde.
Sando, danke für den Sub. Abo-Falle, zugeschnappt.
So, YouTube, letzte Chance uns was zu empfehlen, was ich unbedingt sehen will.
Nope. Kondome durchlöchert. Moment, was für ein Ding?
Reverse? Stealthing? Was für ein Ding?
Okay, für was es nicht alles Wörter gibt. Neuestes Video von Lohnt-sich-das.
Das heben wir uns für einen der nächsten Tage auf. Da ist bestimmt auch wieder was,
wo ich am Ende streamen, ein paar runden Videos gucke, so zum Ausklang.
Da gucken wir uns das dann an. Ich schau mal schnell, ob wir irgendjemand
raiden können.
Alles klar, Leute. Wir sehen uns. Bis zum nächsten Stream, machts gut,
see you.